to make it better but they failed
basically
having spoken to regulators about the
lessons from the financial crisis
it's pretty clear where the weaknesses
still lie
generally on all the reforms that i've
done since the financial crisis
we've made them better but we probably
haven't made them good enough
so there's there's really not been
fundamental changes we've kind of made
these improvements
around the edges i think people should
still be concerned and think there's
this kind of assumption
that it's yesterday's news and i think
that's probably
ill-advised because i think there's
still some real fragility in the system
as a senior investment banking executive
recently told me
his chief financial officer would not be
able to challenge him
on on what's in his box you need a phd
to understand a lot of these
transactions
and you know the people in charge are
often
don't have those phds it is not an awful
lot to be confident about
what's really lurking inside financial
institutions balance sheets
and it remains just as difficult for the
outside world
to get into them yes it's true the
higher management often doesn't
understand
much at all actually which of course is
a serious problem
when there is a crisis not unlike what
we saw
in the lead-up to the global financial
crisis where it was mortgage debt
that had ballooned this time it's
corporate debt
the market has grown enormously and
i believe that there's a recession
coming
or a market crash coming and it's a
government matter it's a political
matter
and whether or not the politicians will
be able to sort something out i'm very
pessimistic about that
quick take charge where are you bringing
today's top news and break down how it
intersects with the world of business
i'm tim stenovich and i'm jennifer's
abasaga in new york it's friday april
23rd we have a lot to get to so let's
get going
[Music]
good morning everyone and happy friday
let's start though with bitcoin
which is not having so great of a friday
heading for its worst week in
more than a year the world's largest
digital currency extended losses after
president biden proposed almost
doubling the capital gains tax for those
who make a million dollars or more a
year
and it said investors rushing to get out
well they could and
sell their bitcoin resulting in the
biggest drop in stocks in more than a
month
here to break down why this matters to
retail investors is the ceo of the
fintech company skilling michael cameron
and also bloomberg's wall street
reporter shanali basic a big thank you
to both of you for being here
chanel i want to start with you um why
does a tax proposal
aimed at just the top three tenths of
one percent have such a dramatic effect
on the stock market well it's amazing
tim because you have the situation where
wealthy people are the folks that engage
most
in the stock market so that's by means
of you know their own
personal trading their their own
accounts but it's also by means of
family offices as we know right now
so that's one thing but it's more uh
smoke than fire right i mean there's
this you say tax and it's like the
market freaks out
mike novogratz who we interview on this
program um you know quite frequently
at huber bloomberg he has been warning
of this
for many many months right before the
election even started that
we can expect more uh capital gains i
mean the president himself was warning
about this during his campaign like this
didn't come out of nowhere
no surprise how and especially because
you know frankly
what we are talking about now is more
contained than many on wall street even
believed would be happening
but i think what's happening now is the
fact that it's becoming closer
to reality that's spooking people uh a
little bit and what the ramifications
might be of it
and michael how much do you read into
this news and how does the retail
investor sort of interpret everything
that has happened this past week
i i don't think that it's going to be a
long-term drag on
on the the price of bitcoin and i don't
think that retail traders are going to
see
a lot of uh they're not going to see it
as an impediment to long-term price
change like
long-term price growth so for for
you know from my perspective i don't
think it's going to be a long-term drag
for clients
um michael talk a little bit about why
we're seeing the
drag on coins that we've seen right
right this week i mean over the weekend
there was some
concern about regulation that didn't end
up
coming to fruition or at least we didn't
even get more details about that
uh but but why are we seeing a bitcoin
headed for its its worst week in a month
i think it's a classic uh buy the rumor
sell the news so
i think there was a lot of uh a lot of
the the smart money on bitcoin
uh specifically bitcoin was watching the
coinbase ipo
and in the weeks and months leading up
to it knew that that would be a
watershed moment
for the industry and then more
specifically for bitcoin so they were
you know increasingly getting involved
in bitcoin and then as soon as the ipo
hit
that's when the news came out so i think
it was a very stereotypical buy the
rumor cell to
sell the news story and i think that has
a lot to do a lot to do with it and some
profit taking but i don't think it's
i think that for all the bitcoin
enthusiasts and hardcore you know uh
bitcoin traders it's it's just going to
be another leg down before another leg
up and
a lot of their opinions chanel
how are your sources on on wall street
reacting right that whole buy the rumor
sell the news thing
it's a real thing right i mean there's
something about this that people like
dips right it's where they
buy the most um but even beyond that
something interesting about uh
crypto that i wanted to point out and
i'm stealing a note here from bloomberg
opinions brian chapata who who makes
this point
you know bitcoin if you tax it what
makes it harder for people
is that it makes it harder as a form of
payment right and
that's where people want to see more
adoption and payment i'm really curious
about what michael thinks about this too
because you know we did see news this
week jen
we saw news you know we work for example
warming up to cryptocurrencies
and i've been wondering all year you
know what is the marginal value of more
companies getting
uh getting in on crypto what is the
marginal value of more big crypto news
because we've seen such a run-up this
year
already um you know what is the next big
thing to happen in crypto that will give
um you know the prices another leg up
michael do you have that i can speak
properly i can speak from our
perspective we
you know we see a lot of requests for
you know we you know in our industry in
online trading we see a lot of requests
for
funding accounts uh with with
cryptocurrencies and it's still not
widely
widely used in our industry uh there's
still kind of a lot of the
the stereotypical concerns that that uh
financial institutions have always had
about cryptocurrencies but as as big
names like paypal
and venmo move into these spaces and as
coinbase
has now gone public and is likely the
first of many
uh and there's you know reporting
requirements and good governance
requirements there i think that the the
payment space is going to see a lot of
shake up with crypto i think payments is
going to
when it start piercing into markets
where they're not you know it's not
really that common
so you know we're seeing it in our
industry we're seeing a lot of clients
say hey i'd like to fund i i know i can
fund via
the the typical methods but i've got
cryptocurrencies especially since
there's been a big run-up in price i'd
like to take advantage of that yeah can
i fund
those and i think that's going to grow
hey michael i i i want to ask about
the idea and and shenali mentioned this
the idea of
more and more companies starting to
accept cryptocurrency as a payment the
wework news of course that you talked
about
uh and then also venmo and and paypal
paypal has been doing this for months at
this point
um but tesla just a few months ago um
and then of course what microstrategy
has been doing for a long time with
adding
cryptocurrency and bitcoin specifically
to its balance sheet i posed this
question though to the ceo of chipotle
yesterday
who we interviewed on bloomberg
businessweek radio to ask him if if they
have any plans to start accepting
bitcoin
and he really he pretty much laughed me
off with that with the question like
you know like no it's not it's something
that they've talked about but they have
no plans to do that
and they certainly have no plans to add
bitcoin to their balance sheet um
if if we don't see widespread adoption
of actually accepting it
as a currency is is there a limit to how
high it goes
i think that's a very uh i think that's
i think that's a wrong way to look at it
so we operate in our in our industry we
operate in a very international space so
we don't we don't have um we don't we
don't we don't have american customers
number one but we have customers from
all over the world
and um you know within western europe
and the united states and canada
the forms of payment methods are very
they're great they're highly developed
they're quick
um but in other parts of the world
there's a there's a real use case
for being able to move your money around
and it being accepted as a form of
payment
so i think that for a company like
chipotle i'm you know i'm a customer
they're a great company
but they uh you know they don't they
probably don't have that that
as large as international customer base
as companies in my industry do
so we have a real need for customers
have a real need and desire to do that
and i think that i think this is only i
think if you laugh it out of the room i
think that
i think the time the history is not on
your side i think this is a wave that's
coming you think you have to adopt it
there's ways to adopt it in manners that
will
jive with uh with what the typical
financial institutions are looking for
so there's
a real growing contingent of companies
that are
answering the questions that these
institutions have specifically around
anti-money laundering and
and monitoring transactions that are
maybe nefarious there's ways now to
track that and there's ways to monitor
those things that are
you know widely used by law enforcement
agencies government agencies etc so
i think that's the wrong tack to take i
think that i think you need to be
accepting of these new technologies
and so then michael how are you advising
your customers about sort of what's next
and what they should be paying attention
to
in terms of payments or in terms of
which cryptocurrencies are moving
which cryptocurrencies are moving so we
we offer uh one of the widest varieties
of cryptos in our in our space so we
offer 22 cryptocurrency products
we are we don't do any advising we don't
tell people to buy this or sell that we
leave that to the customer base we
we support a retail customer base like i
said from all over the world
and um and and we leave it up to them
but we actively monitor what people are
looking for and what they're talking to
us about so if
if today polka dot is rising and
tomorrow it's bitcoin cash and monday
it's dogecoin
um we're actively following that and
putting it on our platform so that if
customers want to find these things that
it's
they're easily accessible hey michael
you know i do want to kind of bring this
back into the tax conversation because i
feel like it's a really important one
especially because it's not something
that's going to be imminent it's going
to be a big ugly fight in washington
and it will probably create more
volatility as that goes along
what does what do these tax changes
have directly in terms of
um bitcoin prices and also adoption of
bitcoin as people look for it as a
payment method
i i don't i don't think it's going to
have the impact the the long-term impact
that i think that we're discussing here
today i i think that
this is a bitcoin is not a uniquely
american product
i think that this this tax conundrum
that that we may find ourselves in will
have a short-term blip
on some of the larger uh fam from some
of the family offices some of the high
net worth individuals and when they buy
in the way they they view this as an
investment um but
the rest of the world i don't think
there's going to be a high correlation
to
you know that dragging on the price long
term i think that international
investors
will read the story find interest in it
but it's not going to act as a drag so i
don't think it's going to have the
long-term impact
that uh that some think it may michael
cameron ceo of
skilling companies skilling and
bloomberg shinali basic
big thank you to both of you for your
time now we don't want to bury the lead
on the rest of the morning's top news so
here are some stories we do not want you
to miss
well it's day two of president biden's
virtual climate summit the goal was to
send the message that the u.s is back
and ready to lead many of the 40 heads
of state taking part had their own
message for america
prove it president biden announced a new
commitment to reduce emissions but the
50
cut below 2005 levels may not even be
compatible with the paris climate
agreement
and u.s vaccine experts meet today to
review johnson johnson's coronavirus
shot
it's been on hold for 10 days after
several cases of rare and serious blood
clots
the panel of experts advises the cdc the
15 voting members will
debate whether the shot should be used
again in the u.s
and japanese tire maker bridgestone says
it will support the tokyo olympics and
paralympic games is a key sponsor
as long as the safety of participants is
secured in an interview with
bloomberg ceo shushi ishibashi said that
it
will refrain from holding a big
marketing campaign and won't invite
overseas guests you can always learn
more about these stories and stay up to
date on the day's news at bloomberg.com
and coming up black americans have died
at twice the rate
of white americans due to covet 19 and
yet the vaccine gap remains
in most of the u.s so how do we narrow
it we're talking to a professor of
epidemiology
next we'll be back in two minutes this
is quick take charge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
so this is the difference
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york well it's time now for quick take
by the numbers it's where we give you
the numbers that
tell the story this morning's number is
seven only seven states in the u.s have
cut their black vaccine gap in half
that's according to data from the
bloomberg vaccine tracker which tracks
data from 44 states and washington dc
and cities as well but now that almost
all adults in the u.s
are eligible for coveted vaccines the
racial and ethnic disparities in who's
getting shots are narrowing
it's especially true in alabama
louisiana maryland mississippi and north
carolina
where black vaccine gaps have narrowed
from 10 points or more
to between 2.7 and 6.4 points
idaho and oregon have also improved
their gaps by
more than half though had much greater
equity to start
overall states are still lagging and
vaccinating black and hispanic people
despite a greater supply of vaccines and
few eligibility requirements a dozen
states have vaccinated 25
or more of their black population and
only nine have
done as well with hispanic people almost
every place we track has done at least
as well with white people
with a handful of states that have
vaccinated almost half of their white
populations
joining us now to discuss how the u.s
can target these populations is
associate professor of epidemiology at
the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health kerry
altoff
carrie thanks so much for being with us
this morning so you know as you
as you mentioned as we've talked about
we were able to target
older adults uh getting vaccinated early
on
why aren't we able to do the same with
minority communities
so older adults did have a pretty steep
barrier technologically wise in some
communities in order to access those
vaccine appointments
but the barriers for accessing vaccine
for black and latino communities
they can be very very different in
addition to perhaps some technology gaps
that could occur there
there's also work people are working
people need access to vaccine
from specific areas that are close to
them um
and and walk-up options they also need
it in their communities if it's too far
for them to access when we see these
gaps in terms of
the even just looking at the proportion
of black and latino americans
and that they're lagging behind that
tells us right there
we need to do more to get the vaccine to
them so it is about reducing those
barriers
it's also about the messenger which is a
really important part of this
it's about ensuring that trust that
individuals
um can go into the communities we can
work with those community partners
churches community organizations to help
us pull people together to get the
vaccine
but it should be also noted that in a
number of recent polls
we have not seen vaccine hesitancy rates
extraordinarily high in black americans
as compared to right
yeah i think that's a really good point
because it goes against the narrative
that emerged at the beginning of this
which was that uh there was a more
hesitancy among certain demographics of
people in the united states and it's
turning out not necessarily to be the
case dr altaf as you point out
a lot of it has to do with access and
i'm wondering what specific steps can be
taken to
improve that access here in new york for
example they're starting to do
walk-in appointments for some residents
depending on whether or not
you qualify among certain criteria
certain age groups
i'm wondering if that's the way to do it
because then you don't have to worry
about making that appointment you don't
have to
worry about finding that time that
actually works you have to stay up late
trying to find that slot in a in a place
that is close to where you live
absolutely walk-ins are essential but
then it's also making sure that you have
the staff
and the vaccine supply so that those
weights are not
incredibly long because people will come
after work
on the weekend during these different
times when they have a chance but
nobody has the time then to wait in line
for three hours for that appointment so
it is about walk-ins it's also about
making sure
that those walk-in locations are located
to where people can access them
and that they are fully staffed and have
ample vaccine supply
it's also about putting vaccine on vans
and driving into communities if you
cannot get
a site set up right there it's also
about engaging with
employers especially large-scale
employers to think about how vaccination
could be brought into the workplace and
carrie i mean at the same time as we're
talking about this the ap this morning
has a story out saying
that louisiana and some other southern
states have had
have asked the federal government to cut
back on how much
vaccine shipments they are getting
because of um
the decrease in demand that there is so
how concerning
is that for you especially given what
you're saying you know
um that we still need to get these
populations vaccinated
um and we're hearing that you know there
are some states that are asking for
smaller shipments at this point in time
so we knew this point
would come at some point where we have
met the demand and then the supply would
exceed the demand
and really we're in in a place in some
states where and in some locations in
states
where there are individuals where
there's greater vaccine hesitancy there
was a
recent poll out that looked at more
rural white americans
expressing more vaccine hesitancy and
saying
we will not be vaccinated unless forced
to and so this is one of those
situations where
um thinking through instead of just
saying hold on the vaccine
it's thinking through okay who are the
right messengers to go in
and explore why there's so much vaccine
hesitancy
what information and communication is
needed because at the end of the day
just like we're seeing not only in our
rural areas
in our urban areas all across america
it's going to take
everyone to build sufficient immunity
in the us as well as worldwide professor
altoff as we mentioned earlier in the
show vaccine experts meet today to
review johnson johnson's shot it has
been on hold
for 10 days i wonder to what extent the
single shot from jnj plays into
getting these next portion of americans
vaccinated because
with that shot you are one and done
absolutely um it's also a shot that can
can travel
pretty well can go on in the communities
so there are a lot of
a lot of really good things the
important part
about what we're doing with this j j
vaccine right now
is that we are digging deeply into the
safety we are anxious to hear what acip
says today um particularly if there are
any new cases that have been discovered
that should be presented today
we should have a full understanding i
think most scientists anticipate that
vaccine will be put back into use due to
just how rare
this uh blood clotting situation is but
there may be
important recommendations guidelines
different things for clinicians and
public health
workers to understand about who maybe
should not
be vaccinated with this type of vaccine
it is also about rebuilding that
confidence that i think we have lost
a bit to say you know what yes there are
side effects
this is one we fully investigated here
is the benefit
to this vaccine particularly when we're
still seeing hundreds and hundreds of
deaths from chromovirus a day
in this country associate professor of
epidemiology at the johns hopkins at
bloomberg school of public health
professor kerry altoff carey thanks so
much for your time always great to have
you on the show we should note that the
johns hopkins bloomberg school of public
health is supported by michael r
bloomberg
founder of bloomberg lp and bloomberg
philanthropies
well coming up next paul krugman shares
his predictions on the u.s economy
we'll be back in two minutes this is
quick take charge
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zaba and i'm tim stenovec in new york
well with widespread optimism around u.s
economic recovery nobel laureate paul
krugman gave our friends at bloomberg tv
his perspective on the u.s economy and a
proposal from the bible administration
to double the capital gains tax here's
what he predicts
i'm still not entirely sure that we've
got the pandemic
under control you know we think we've
got it but a little bit alarming
and look i i am um we are
they'll put this way larry summons is
not being completely
uh foolish here there is a it's a lot of
money that we're throwing at the economy
and
uh it could be it could be a problem
although i think we have ways to deal
with it but
uh so we're giving a really big boost to
the to things right now
i mean i'm very optimistic but but
there's always some
there's both downside and upside risk
both both that you know pandemic hits us
again or
that this thing goes too fast and you
know we're starting to see bottlenecks
things uh there are a lot of problems
with with a
rapid recovery when we still have
disrupted supply chains so
this could be no it's not going to be
totally smooth sailing well i am curious
when you look at the supply chains we've
been talking a lot about some of the
inflationary pressures
out there whether it's in some of the
commodities or now and some of the
consumer staples here
some of that of course is sort of tied
to the economy sort of reheating but a
lot of that is also tied here to the
disruptions that we had because of covid
and i'm wondering if maybe that uh if we
if you consider some of those
disruptions to be temporary
that the inflationary pressures might
not be as heavy as some people think
yeah i think it's going to be important
and i think the people at the fed know
this that
core inflation is actually not a
sufficient a sufficient statistic here
uh
that even you know normally we think
that okay this transitory stuff is
basically food and energy
but now there's going to be transitory
shortage as well you know uh chips
uh lumber uh the uh there's a shortage
of containers
uh so there's a lot of sort of unusual
disruptions all of which is not
fundamental
uh all of which doesn't mean that we
actually are seeing an up
a rise in underlying inflation it just
means that we're hitting some
some bottlenecks as we come back from a
highly disrupted economy and stuff that
should be disregarded
in in terms of setting policy and so
don't we all have big buttons that say
don't panic uh
on the inflation front sending policy
from a monetary policy front there when
it comes to inflation when it comes to
labor data but
there's also of course what the
government is up to and
asset prices well maybe a bit of
inflation pressure took a leg around
today because they were worried about
capital gains taxes coming forward what
do you think about
the inevitability or not of tax
increases and what it means for the
overall economy
well yeah there's going to be i mean
that's a little bit weird right we had
uh
this is something that biden had said
all along he was going to
try to do and now he says i'm going to
try to do what i promised i was going to
do in the market
although we get if if a 1 fall in stock
prices
is is all that you get from a really
major increase in capital gains taxes
that's
that's not a big problem um but yeah i
mean the
the biden has an ambitious agenda
we have a some fiscal space interest
rates are extremely low
we have learned that debt fears are
exaggerated but we don't have infinite
fiscal space
so some significant tax increases
are going to be part of the story and
biden is trying to do those with
not hitting the middle class at all so
it's supposed to be
corporate taxes and then high taxes high
incomes capital gains
uh it's so but something like this is
pretty much inevitable unless
everything is you know fails
because still this stuff could still
stumble in congress it's possible still
that
that uh you know they they need all 50
senators but
plus kamala harris to pass any of this
stuff but but assuming that they're
going to get through with this stuff
they are going to need some taxes to pay
for at least part of it
and and that was economist paul krugman
speaking thursday with bloomberg's
romaine bostic and caroline hyde now
coming up u.s gymnast simone biles is
ending her contract with nike
and entering a new partnership with
athleta we've got all the details and
what it means for nike's future
as well as the as the power today's
athletes are wielding in the business
world we'll be back in two minutes
this is quick take charge
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim steinovich
and i'm jennifer zabasanja in new york
now to big news
shaking up both the sports world and the
business world this morning in a
surprise
move famed olympic gymnast simone biles
is leaving nike for a partnership
with athleta which athletic calls in a
press release
a shared vision designed to empower
women
and girls this comes days after nike's
partnership with kobe bryant's estate
expired
and two years after allison felix left
nike for athleta after she criticized
nike
for failing to support pregnant athletes
so what does this all mean for nike and
is this a trend that we are going to
continue to see so we are very excited
to have both bloomberg opinion columnist
sarah halzick join us from washington dc
and quick take chief correspondent
jason kelly joining us for this
discussion so sarah jason thank you both
for being here this is really a
fascinating story sarah we wanted to
start with you
how significant is this for athleta
to get a partnership with a massive
athlete like simone biles
this is huge athleta is still it's a
fast-growing brand but it's a relatively
small
brand in the athletic wear universe it
does about a billion in sales it's on
track for about 2 billion in sales
in 2023 but it's a cornerstone of gaps
growth strategy
as that chain's namesake brand and the
banana republic brand
kind of struggle to stay relevant it's
all about old navy and athleta to keep
a gap in good shape and this is like a
really
important step in that direction because
one of the challenges for athleta has
been how does it distinguish itself from
lululemon a competitor
that's really similar and firing on all
cylinders
and this will help it achieve that jason
come on in here
i was really struck by something that
simone biles told the wall street
journal
in her interview around this news she
said quote i felt like it wasn't just
about my achievements it's what i stood
for
and how they were going to help me use
my voice and also be a voice for female
athletes and kids i feel like they also
support me not just as an athlete
but as an individual outside of the gym
and the change that i want to create
which is so refreshing jason you've
covered the business of sports for years
i'm wondering how this symbolizes the
different way that athletes are feeling
about
the types of companies that they're
aligning themselves with and also
how they want to push for change outside
of what they're doing professionally
for the greater society well tim i think
that comment that simone miles
files made is a very 2021 sentiment and
it's interesting you know she's signing
this deal
when she's 24 she was 18 i believe when
she signed with nike
those intervening six years for her as
an athlete for her as a businesswoman
in many ways for the world at large and
what athletes stand for
massive things have changed and i think
it symbolizes a lot
about the power that athletes are taking
back in terms of literally and
figuratively
owning their own brands and deciding who
they want to be
both as she has said in the gym and and
outside
so they are voting with their feet and
and ultimately
you know with the dollars that they
carry with them and and the markets and
and the audiences that they have jason
do you think this is something we're
going to continue seeing i mean
you know you've spoken to a number of
athletes um is
is this the way that they are headed
hundred percent i mean i i can't tell
you if you saw my inbox and the pictures
that i get almost every day about
you know this athlete investing here you
know whether it's
the sort of obvious well-known examples
like lebron james or aaron rodgers or
you know you look at what sue bird and
megan rapino have been doing in in both
speaking out and i know that's a story
you followed closely jen
you know this is a new era in many ways
and it is this sense of
ownership in all senses of the word both
the financial aspect of it
but also the the symbolic aspect of it
and
i think it's only going to continue and
as i talk to even younger athletes
high school college athletes they're
thinking along these lines
this is the business they want to be in
uh as they continue their careers and
beyond
hey sarah how big of a loss is this for
nike uh
this is a company that in recent years
has struggled with
news reports about the way that it
treats female employees and also
female athletes athletes who have gotten
pregnant
while they've been under contract from
nike as the wall street journal points
out and has been widely reported
how big of a loss is this for nike's
brand
so i don't think it's that big of a loss
from a dollar standpoint
you know nike still has a real
murderer's row of sponsored athletes
but i do think the optics of this are
not good for nike as you point out
they've had
this steady trickle of headlines about
their treatment of
female athletes and about their
workplace culture being toxic for women
and here uh you have this really high
profile athlete whose
uh you know powers are going to be on
full display this summer at the tokyo
games
um and she has defected to go to a much
smaller brand so
yeah i i don't think um the optics are
good for nike and
you know to jason's earlier points i i
think that this
belies not just where athletes are but
where young consumers are right now
this idea to sort of um have align
yourself with brands that are consistent
with your values
we see this with the way that many gen z
folks are shopping
um and so it's not surprising to me that
gen z and young millennial athletes are
operating this way too
and sarah i mean nike put out a
statement wishing simone the best but
saying that
they plan to continue to evolve and
support female athletes i mean
what what do you think is their next
move i mean you mentioned
they're going to be on full display this
summer but um you know
how how do they win back these young
consumers
yeah so i think that they continue to uh
build they're really trying to put a lot
of energy behind
their women's business behind making the
garments and sneakers aimed at women
uh you know fine-tuning that business
and making those garments better and i
think that will help
they've also taken steps like um you
know nike only just recently added
maternity workout wear
that was something they didn't even
offer that uh other competitors have had
uh for quite some time
so i think those are subtle signals to
women that they are
really trying to design for their
lifestyle and for
for them for the unique needs of them as
athletes hey jason
when are these companies going to really
feel like they're starting to lead
when it comes to these things and not
necessarily follow the lead of athletes
here
it certainly feels like these companies
obviously are huge and the
decision-making process is a long time
but
increasingly like you explored with your
with your business of sports
uh special that took place in georgia um
the way that that
individuals and sports teams want to
lead here um how do you see companies
doing this
i think companies realize they need the
athletes in a much more meaningful way i
mean
it's a it's a term that's thrown around
and i'm sure sarah and i would both
and all of you as journalists would sort
of roll your eyes we all roll our eyes
when we hear about well this is a
partnership
i i actually think it does have to be a
much more intimate relationship
you know between these athletes and the
companies because
as demonstrated by this simone biles
news they'll walk
you know like they have they feel much
more emboldened it used to be something
where this was only in the nba or the
wnba you know those were the examples of
player activism
and and real power this is now extending
across the entire sports landscape
across
all sorts of sports and all ages as we
talked about earlier so
i think companies need to get religion
on the fact that
these athletes have power that is not
going away and platforms that they are
very willing to use
bloomberg sarah halzak and jason kelly a
big thank you to both of you
for your time well sticking with sports
portland at trailblazer center ines
cantor is consistently using his
platform to speak out on
social justice and human rights issues
cantor knows that
there is still a long fight ahead for
equality and urges that quote
we need unity more than anything else
our vanessa perdomo caught up with
cantor check it out
so the last time we spoke was right
after nba players protested games
due to the police shooting of jacob lake
and we just saw
derek chovin was found guilty for
murdering george floyd which is another
police shooting that nba players were
really outspoken against
what is the feeling like amongst players
in the league right now after this
guilty verdict was announced well you
know like everyone else obviously i
followed the
derek children trial like most of the
country not just
nba players but most of the country you
know just a friend
and for justice for george floyd and
obviously
um jury you know found them guilty on
all three
accounts you know manslaughter and
murder but uh
you know they made the decision pretty
swiftly
and the facts were all there and the
evidence was all there
and the powerful video uh the whole
world saw
and we can finally say that
justice was a serve and i think it's a
huge step forward for
you know the social justice equality and
you know i believe uh you know we need
to remember that that is only just
one case of uh so so many you know
and you know it begs the question you
know if it were not
for that video would we have this kind
of
a sort of justice you know and so
it is well what it takes so i believe
you know black lives
always matter no matter what so yes i
feel like this was a huge
step forward but i feel like we need to
we need to make a systematic change and
as everyone says and everyone knows and
all them vapor
players are saying that we have a long
fight ahead of us so we just need to
keep uh pushing and just uh and try to
inspire our young
generation as much as we can how do you
push forward
to make sure that this isn't just a
one-off case that this does continue
to be the um the verdict if you're an
athlete
actor singer rapper or you know if you
have a platform i feel like we need to
use this platform to inspire as many
people we can especially our young
generation the other thing is uh for
sure you know just
there there is a bill out there called
george uh foster
bill and other other things we
definitely should
have pushed our politicians
senators congressmen congresswomans to
you know just
talk about these issues more and more
because this is only
one case there are so many cases out
there uh
you know so that that's why i feel like
we need to use our
platform to try to spot as much as we
can
and you do use your platform more than a
lot of people do you're a huge advocate
for human rights
one of the things that you just teamed
up with israeli ambassador gilad erdogan
on a op-ed for against anti-semitism
can you tell me how that partnership
came to be and why as someone who's not
jewish you still felt
compelled to speak on this issue when i
met with ambassador
gila derdon obviously he's a huge
basketball fan
i met him this last last summer in new
york
me and him sit down had an amazing
conversation
and uh you know i was like it doesn't
matter what your religion is your
background or your
your skin color or your whatever you are
you know the most important thing in
life is leave your difference on
the table and try to find what we have
in common because we only have one world
to live you know and so i was like let's
let's bring our powers together and try
to bring
uh you know awareness of where what's
going on
not just anti-semitism but i'm a phobia
and and all the other issues around the
world because
i feel like we need unity more than
everything
you know so that's why he's in big
basketball and
by the way he came to our game in
miami down to uh miami and he had an
amazing time so
i'm glad that i have a friend like him
absolutely and speaking of unity in that
way
he's a politician and you're a
professional athlete worlds that
necessarily
a lot of people wouldn't think collide
because politics does
divide a lot of people and sports is
seen as something to bring people
together
so do you think that colliding those
worlds is even more powerful in the
message of unity
of course obviously you know because i
mean uh
i feel like you know he has a huge uh
following and obviously i have a huge
following because of the nba platform so
i feel like bring those powers
together is definitely creating more
awareness
you know he is a jewish ambassador and a
muslim athlete so when this two
person comes together to to to talk
about unity talk about uh islamophobia
to talk about anti-semitism talk about
what can we do to bring more
peace and love and fight against
hate you know people just stops and say
wow
this is very unique we never never seen
this kind of collaboration
before so i think it's you know it's
it's all about you know uh
fighting for uh one thing and it's uh
it's the
fighting against hate anna's thanks so
much for joining us and we'll continue
to look for
what you and other athletes do to help
bring social justice issues forward
thank you honestly appreciate it
and that was portland trailblazers
center ennis cantor speaking with our
vanessa perdomo coming up spacex has
successfully sent
astronauts into space on a rocket that's
already been used
we'll discuss what this means for the
future of space travel in two minutes
this is quick take charge
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
pretty cool stuff there hey welcome back
to quick take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york well there you see four astronauts
beginning their cruise to the
international space station aboard a
spacex capital in the capsule in the
company's
first crude trip this one with a
reusable
rocket spacex has championed the goal of
designing spacecraft for multiple
missions as the only practical and
economical method to lower launch costs
and expand human
exploration specifically to mars with us
now from san francisco it's bloomberg's
ed ludlow
uh ed it's so great to have you on the
show to talk about this i
gotta say to our viewers to everyone
watching you pulled an all-nighter to
make this happen so we really appreciate
that
um how big of a step forward is this for
spacex
given that it's it's able to use uh
these recycled materials these
these actual recycled uh products uh to
uh
to to to head to the space station how
big of a step is it for the company and
for the us space
program yeah that's really the point
here because it's not the first time
obviously that spacex has carried human
beings to international space station we
had the demo in may of last year
and then the first crew dragon team went
up soon after that
it was the first time that the spacex
carried humans recycling both the
capsule
crew dragon the thing that the
astronauts actually sit in and the
falcon 9 rocket the booster
which propels it at launch um and it's
you know actually a question of
economics you know back when nasa relied
on the shuttle program
it was at a cost of hundreds of millions
of dollars per launch and really what
spacex has been able to do
by by reusing both the booster the
rocket and the capsule
is dramatically reduce the cost for nasa
to get human beings and supplies
and you know running supply maintenance
missions to international space station
which means they're more frequent we're
seeing people go up into space
more frequently humans in orbit more
frequently and as one astronaut put it
yesterday just before launch this is the
golden age of space travel that really
is the significance of
of friday's launch and ed i mean as tim
mentioned
you were up all night sort of covering
the story what was it like for you
to watch it this morning with with the
rest of the world i mean
what was your reaction to it yeah it's
an interesting experience i would urge
viewers to go back on youtube and what
relax watch the launch not just that one
but the crew one launch
as well because you can follow the
chronology the series of events
you know the first thing that happens is
launch of course then after about 60
seconds
the rocket reaches max q that's when the
rocket's under the most stress that it
will be
the thrusters go to max we're traveling
at supersonic speed
about 90 seconds later the first stage
of the rocket separates from the second
stage and crew dragon carries on
using a secondary booster a few minutes
later after that
it separates from the secondary boost of
the capsule and at that point
the capsule is 200 kilometers above
earth and and
starts to conduct this series of
complicated maneuvers but there are
risks along the way if you listen
to ground control they will give call
signs and announcements for the
different abort zones that's the
opportunity
that the dragon capsule has to disengage
to remove itself from the boosters in
the event of emergency and it also has
those three parachutes as well but it
but it's tense
and on the other side you know i'm a
journalist i want to be objective
but it's just i'm a huge space romantic
this is exciting
i like rockets i like spiders i like
star wars films who doesn't
and really you know it's completely fair
to say that what spacex and nasa have
done
excuse me over the last six months is
they have captured the imagination not
just to people in north america
but globally about what's possible
because this is the first time in a
decade
that we've launched humans from a u.s
launch
site the first time ever that that a us
agency has carried issa uh the european
space agency and japan agency
uh uh astronauts since they shut down
the shuttle
program so we've come a long way ed i
should note that you know you say you
say romantic i describe myself as a nerd
i much prefer the way that you describe
it as a space romantic
you know i think back though ed you know
i've been following spacex for years and
if we think back to just a few years ago
the company made history with a rocket
that landed
on the drone ship that's become routine
at this point
it's not even a big deal when the
company does that anymore
when does this not become a big deal
when is it routine to just use recycled
spacecraft to send people to the iss and
beyond
whether without something boring there
is some some regulatory considerations
right so the
the crew dragon the capsule is certified
for five flights
so so so it has a maximum life now elon
musk was speaking on friday morning
about the falcon 9 in particular the
booster the actual rocket
and about how many times it can be
reused and
the the short answer is that they will
just keep reusing it
until it no longer works but not using
humans
as the test for that that's too risky
spacex is also working on starlink right
that is it's
a network of low orbit satellites that
provide
internet connection to people around the
world and they use the same falcon 9
booster rocket
for that as they do for the human
launches so they're basically saying
what we can do is use them
until they no longer work but remember
when spacex was founded in 2002 which
seems a long time ago now
it was with the goal of putting humans
onto other planets i'm talking about
mars
so this is incredibly exciting and we
are being a little bit futuristic
but elon musk and spacex are looking
well past supply missions and rotation
of astronauts to iss they're already
thinking about mars
and populating the human species on
other planets
and when they're able to do that with
starship the next generation of rocket
that's really when this becomes
a little redundant all right we're going
to have to leave it there
space romantic bloomberg's ed ludlow who
hasn't slept at all
but is the perfect person to speak to
about this this morning ed ludlow thanks
so much hopefully you get some sleep but
we really appreciate your time
and coming up some good news about
investments made on earth day
we'll be back in two minutes this is
quick take charge
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics
of global warming we can and we will
deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenovec
and i'm jennifer zabasaja in new york
let's look at some developing stories we
are tracking
this morning so in ukraine russia
is starting to withdraw thousands of
troops from areas near the ukrainian
border today ukraine
says it welcomes the move and that it
reduces tension
western leaders had called on moscow to
pull the troops back
there were fears the conflict could lead
to new economic
sanctions and in china
and in china president xi jinping's next
target in the tech crackdown is the
country's vast reams of data china is
forecast to hold
about a third of the world's data by
2025. last month
she promised to go after platform
companies that amass
data to create monopolies and gobble up
smaller
competitors and finally in london
climate activists continued a series of
protests on friday morning
dumping a pile of fake coal outside the
lloyds of london
building blocking the entrance the
insurance rebellion group accused
lloyd's insurers of fueling climate
change by
supporting fossil fuel projects
including the adani carmichael coal mine
in australia
lloyds has said it will stop insuring
coal oil sands and arctic energy
projects
by 2030. activists activists also
defaced
property of hsbc in london yesterday
and you can get and you can get caught
up on all the day's news at
bloomberg.com or our quick take on
social media
well now it's time for some quick take
good news on this friday morning
thursday was earth day and investors
celebrated by pouring a record amount of
money
into a carbon market fund that punishes
polluters
the crane shares global carbon etf had
inflows of more than 15 million dollars
on
thursday bringing its total assets to
more than 160 million that's according
to some bloomberg data
it's the largest publicly traded fund
that invests in cap and trade systems
that put an added price on
burning fossil fuels on the day more
than 20 world leaders met at biden's
virtual climate summit
european union carbon futures surged to
a record exceeding
more than 56.68 per metric ton
it's a gain of almost 90 since the start
of 2020.
they are slightly down as of this
morning that's gonna do it for
quick take this hour but there's much
more quick take coming up in just a
minute i'm tim stenovich
and i'm jennifer zabasager you can check
out all of these stories at
bloomberg.com of course
and at quick take on social media thanks
for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
quick take charge where are we bringing
today's top news and break down how it
intersects with the world of business
i'm tim stenovec and i'm jennifer
zabasaja in new york it's friday april
23rd we have a lot to get to so let's
get going
good morning everyone and happy friday
let's start though with bitcoin
which is not having so great of a friday
heading for its worst week in more than
a year
the world's largest digital currency
extended losses after president biden
proposed almost
doubling the capital gains tax for those
who make a million dollars
or more a year and it sent investors
rushing to get out well they could and
sell their bitcoin resulting in the
biggest drop in stocks in more than a
month
here to break down why this matters to
retail investors is the ceo of the
fintech company skilling
michael cameron and also bloomberg's
wall street reporter shanae basic a big
thank you to both of you for being here
charlie i want to start with you um why
does a tax proposal
aimed at just the top three tenths of
one percent have such a dramatic effect
on the stock market well it's amazing
tim because you have the situation where
wealthy people are the folks that engage
most
in the stock market so that's by means
of you know their own personal trading
their their own accounts but it's also
by means of family offices as we know
right now
so that's one thing but it's more uh
smoke than fire right i mean there's
this you say tax and it's like the
market
freaks out uh mike novogratz who we
interview on this program um you know
quite frequently
at bloomberg he has been warning of this
for many many months right before the
election even started that
we can expect more uh capital gains i
mean
the president himself was warning about
this during his campaign like this
didn't come out of nowhere
no surprise how and especially because
you know frankly
what we are talking about now is more
contained than many on wall street even
believed would be happening
but i think what's happening now is the
fact that it's becoming closer
to reality that's spooking people a
little bit and what the ramifications
might be of it
and michael how much do you read into
this news and how does the retail
investor sort of interpret everything
that has happened this past week
i i don't think that it's going to be a
long-term drag on
on the the price of bitcoin and i don't
think that retail traders are going to
see
a lot of uh they're not going to see it
as an impediment to long-term price
change
like long-term price growth so for for
you know for from my perspective i don't
think it's going to be a long-term drag
for clients um michael talk a little bit
about why we're seeing the
drag on coins that we've seen right
right this week i mean over the weekend
there was some
concern about regulation that didn't end
up
coming to fruition or at least we didn't
even get more details about that
uh but but why are we seeing a bitcoin
headed for it's it's worst week in a
month
i think it's a classic uh buy the rumor
sell the news so
i think there was a lot of uh a lot of
the the smart money on bitcoin
uh specifically bitcoin was watching the
coinbase ipo
and in the weeks and months leading up
to it knew that that would be a
watershed moment
for the industry and then more
specifically for bitcoin so they were
you know increasingly getting involved
in bitcoin and then as soon as the ipo
hit
that's when the news came out so i think
it was a very stereotypical buy the
rumor cell to
sell the news story and um i think that
has a lot to do a lot to do with it and
some profit taking but i don't think
it's
i think that for all the bitcoin
enthusiasts and hardcore you know uh
bitcoin traders it's it's just going to
be another leg down before another leg
up and then a lot of their opinions
shanali how are your sources on on wall
street reacting
right that whole by the rumor sell the
news thing is a real thing right i mean
there's something about this that people
like dips right it's where they buy the
most
um but even beyond that something
interesting about uh crypto that i
wanted to point out
and i'm stealing a note here from
bloomberg opinions brian chapata who who
makes this point
you know bitcoin if you tax it what
makes it harder for people
is that it makes it harder as a form of
payment
right and that's where people want to
see more adoption and payment i'm really
curious about what michael thinks about
this too
because you know we did see news this
week jen we saw news
you know wework for example warming up
to cryptocurrencies
and i've been wondering all year you
know what is the marginal value of more
companies getting
uh getting in on crypto what is the
marginal value of more big crypto news
because we've seen such a run-up this
year
already um you know what is the next big
thing to happen in crypto that will give
um you know the prices another leg up
michael do you have that i can speak i
can speak from our perspective we
you know we see a lot of requests for
you know we you know in our industry in
online trading we see a lot of requests
for
funding accounts uh with with
cryptocurrencies and it's still not
widely
widely used in our industry uh there's
still kind of a lot of the
stereotypical concerns that that uh
financial institutions have always had
about cryptocurrencies but as as big
names like paypal
and venmo move into these spaces and as
coinbase has now gone public
and is likely the first of many uh and
there's you know reporting requirements
and good governance
requirements there i think that the the
payment space is going to see a lot of
shake up with crypto i think payments is
going to
when it start piercing into markets
where they're not you know it's not
really that common
so you know we're seeing in our industry
we're seeing a lot of clients say
hey i'd like to fund i i know i can fund
via the the typical methods
but i've got cryptocurrencies especially
since there's been a big run-up in price
i'd like to take advantage of that yeah
can i fund those and i i think that's
going to grow
hey michael i i i want to ask about the
idea
and and shinali mentioned this the idea
of more and more companies starting to
accept cryptocurrency as a payment the
wework news of course that you talked
about
and then also venmo and and paypal uh
paypal's been doing this for months at
this point
um but tesla uh just a few months ago um
and then of course what microstrategy
has been doing for a long time with
adding
cryptocurrency and bitcoin specifically
to its balance sheet i posed this
question though to the ceo of chipotle
yesterday uh who we interviewed on
bloomberg businessweek radio to ask him
if
if they have any plans to start
accepting bitcoin and he really he
pretty much laughed me off
with that with the question like you
know like no it's not it's something
that they've talked about but they have
no plans to do that
and they certainly have no plans to add
bitcoin to their balance sheet um
if if we don't see widespread adoption
of actually accepting it
as a currency is is there a limit to how
high it goes
i think that's a very uh i think that's
i think that's a wrong way to look at it
so we operate in our in our industry we
operate in a very international space so
we don't we don't have we don't we don't
we don't have american customers number
one but we have customers from all over
the world
and you know within western europe and
the united states and canada
the forms of payment methods are very
they're great they're highly developed
they're quick
um but in other parts of the world
there's a there's a real use case
for being able to move your money around
and it being accepted as a form of
payment
so i think that for a company like
chipotle i'm you know i'm a customer
they're a great company
but they uh you know they don't they
probably don't have that
that as large as international customer
base as companies in my industry do
so we have a real need for customers
have a real need and desire to do that
and i think that i think this is only i
think if you laugh it out of the room i
think that
i think the time the history is not on
your side i think this is a wave that's
coming
you i think you have to adopt it there's
ways to adopt it in manners that will
jive with uh with what the typical
financial institutions are looking for
so there's
a real growing contingent of companies
that are
answering the questions that these
institutions have specifically around
anti-money laundering and
and monitoring transactions that are
maybe nefarious there's ways now to
track that and there's ways to monitor
those things that are
you know widely used by law enforcement
agencies government agencies etc so
i think that's the wrong tack to take i
think that i think you need to be
accepting of these new technologies
and so then michael how are you advising
your customers about sort of what's next
and what they should be paying attention
to
in terms of payments or in terms of
which cryptocurrencies are moving
which cryptocurrencies are moving so we
we offer uh one of the widest varieties
of cryptos in our
in our space so we offer 22
cryptocurrency products
we are we don't do any advising we don't
tell people to buy this or sell that we
leave that to the customer base we
we support a retail customer base like i
said from all over the world
and um and and we leave it up to them
but we actively monitor what people are
looking for and what they're talking to
us about so if if today
polka dot is rising and tomorrow it's
bitcoin cash and monday it's dogecoin
um we're actively following that and
putting it on our platform so that if
customers want to find these things that
it's
they're easily accessible hey michael
you know i do want to kind of bring this
back into the tax conversation because i
feel like it's a really important one
especially because it's not something
that's going to be imminent it's going
to be a big ugly fight in washington
and it will probably create more
volatility as that goes along
what does what do these tax changes
have directly in terms of
um bitcoin prices and also adoption of
bitcoin as people look for it as a
payment method
i don't i don't think it's going to have
the impact the the long-term
impact that i think that we're
discussing here today i i think that
this is a bitcoin is not a uniquely
american product
i think that this this tax conundrum
that that we may find ourselves in will
have a short-term blip on some of the
larger
uh fam from some of the family office
some of the high net worth individuals
and when they buy
in the way they they view this as an
investment um but
the rest of the world i don't think
there's going to be a high correlation
to
you know that dragging on the price long
term i think that international
investors
will read the story find interest in it
but i know it's not going to act as a
drag so i don't think it's going to have
the long-term impact
that uh that some think of me michael
cameron ceo of
skilling company skilling and bloomberg
shinali basic big thank you to both of
you
for your time now we don't want to bury
the lead on the rest of the morning's
top news so here are some stories we do
not want you to miss
well it's day two of president biden's
virtual climate summit the goal was to
send the message that the u.s is back
and ready to lead
many of the 40 heads of state taking
part had their own message for america
prove it president biden announced a new
commitment to reduce emissions but the
50
cut below 2005 levels may not even be
compatible with the paris climate
agreement
and u.s vaccine experts meet today to
review johnson johnson's coronavirus
shot
it's been on hold for 10 days after
several cases of rare and serious blood
clots
the panel of experts advises the cdc the
15 voting members will debate whether
the shot should be used again
in the u.s and japanese tire maker
bridgestone says it will support the
tokyo olympics and paralympic games is a
key sponsor
as long as the safety of participants is
secured in an interview with bloomberg
ceo sushi ishibashi said that it will
refrain from holding a big marketing
campaign and
won't invite overseas guests you can
always learn more about these stories
and stay up to date on the day's news at
bloomberg.com
and coming up black americans have died
at twice the rate
of white americans due to covet 19 and
yet the vaccine gap remains
in most of the u.s so how do we narrow
it we're talking to a professor of
epidemiology
next we'll be back in two minutes this
is quick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york well it's time now for quick take
by the numbers it's where we give you
the numbers that
tell the story this morning's number is
seven only seven
states in the u.s have cut their black
vaccine gap in half
that's according to data from the
bloomberg vaccine tracker which tracks
data from 44 states and washington dc
and cities as well but now that almost
all adults in the u.s are eligible for
covered vaccines
the racial and ethnic disparities in
who's getting shots are
narrowing it's especially true in
alabama louisiana maryland mississippi
and north carolina
where black vaccine gaps have narrowed
from 10 points or more
to between 2.7 and 6.4 points
idaho and oregon have also improved
their gaps by
more than half though had much greater
equity to start
overall states are still lagging and
vaccinating black and hispanic people
despite a greater supply of vaccines and
few eligibility requirements a dozen
states have vaccinated 25
or more of their black population and
only nine have
done as well with hispanic people almost
every place we track
has done at least as well with white
people with a handful of states that
have vaccinated almost half
of their white populations
joining us now to discuss how the u.s
can target these populations
is associate professor of epidemiology
at the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health kerry
altoff
carey thanks so much for being with us
this morning so you know as you as you
mentioned as we've talked about
we were able to target older adults
getting vaccinated early on
why aren't we able to do the same with
minority communities
so older adults did have a pretty steep
barrier technologically wise in some
communities in order to access those
vaccine appointments
but the barriers for accessing vaccine
for black and latino communities
they can be very very different in
addition to perhaps some technology gaps
that could occur there
there's also work people are working
people need access to vaccine
from specific areas that are close to
them
and and walk-up options they also need
it in their communities if it's too
far for them to access when we see these
gaps
in terms of the even just looking at the
proportion of
black and latino americans and that
they're lagging behind
that tells us right there we need to do
more to get the vaccine
to them so it is about reducing those
barriers it's also about the messenger
which is a really important part of this
it's about ensuring that trust
that individuals um can go into the
communities
we can work with those community
partners churches
community organizations to help us pull
people together to get the vaccine but
it should be also noted
that in a number of recent polls we have
not seen
vaccine hesitancy rates extraordinarily
high in black americans as compared to
right
yeah i think that's a really good point
because it goes against the narrative
that emerged at the beginning of this
which was that uh there was a more
hesitancy among certain demographics of
people in the united states and it's
turning out not necessarily to be the
case dr altaf as you point out a lot of
it has to do with
access and i'm wondering what specific
steps can be taken to improve that
access here in new york for example
they're starting to do
walk-in appointments for some residents
depending on whether or not you
uh qualify among certain criteria
certain age groups i'm wondering if
that's the way to do it because then you
don't have to worry about making that
appointment you don't have to
worry about finding that time that
actually works you don't have to stay up
late trying to find that slot in a in a
place that is close to where you live
absolutely walk-ins are essential but
then it's also making sure that you have
the staff
and the vaccine supply so that those
weights are not
incredibly long because people will come
after work
on the weekend during these different
times when they have a chance but
nobody has the time then to wait in line
for three hours for that appointment so
it is about walk-ins it's also about
making sure
that those walk-in locations are located
to where people can access them
and that they are fully staffed and have
ample vaccine supply it's also about
putting
vaccine on vans and driving into
communities if you cannot get
a site set up right there it's also
about engaging with employers especially
large-scale employers to think about how
vaccination
could be brought into the workplace and
carrie i mean at the same time as we're
talking about this the ap this morning
has a story out saying
that louisiana and some other southern
states have had have
asked the federal government to cut back
on how much
vaccine shipments they are getting
because of um
the decrease in demand that there is so
how concerning
is that for you especially given what
you're saying you know
um that we still need to get these
populations vaccinated
um and we're hearing that you know there
are some states that are asking for
smaller shipments at this point in time
so we knew this point
would come at some point where we have
met the demand and then the supply would
exceed the demand
and really we're in in a place in some
states where and in some locations in
states
where there are individuals where
there's greater vaccine hesitancy there
was a
recent poll out that looked at more
rural white americans expressing
more vaccine hesitancy and saying we
will not be vaccinated unless forced to
and so this is one of those situations
where i'm
thinking through instead of just saying
hold on the vaccine it's thinking
through okay who are the right
messengers
to go in and explore why there's so much
vaccine hesitancy
what information and communication is
needed because at the end of the day
just like we're seeing not only in our
rural areas
in our urban areas all across america
it's going to take
everyone to build sufficient immunity
in the us as well as worldwide professor
altof as we mentioned
earlier in the show vaccine experts meet
today to review johnson and johnson's
shot it has been on hold
for 10 days i wonder to what extent the
single shot from jnj
plays into getting these next portion of
americans vaccinated because
with that shot you are one and done
absolutely um it's also a shot that can
can travel
pretty well can go on in the communities
so there are a lot of
a lot of really good things the
important part
about what we're doing with this j j
vaccine right now
is that we are digging deeply into the
safety we are anxious to hear what acip
says today particularly if there are any
new cases that have been discovered that
should be presented today we should have
a full
understanding i think most scientists
anticipate the vaccine will be put back
into use due to just
how rare this blood clotting situation
is
but there may be important
recommendations guidelines different
things for clinicians and public health
workers to understand about who maybe
should not
be vaccinated with this type of vaccine
it is also about rebuilding that
confidence that i think we have lost a
bit
to say you know what yes there are side
effects this is one we fully
investigated
here is the benefit to this vaccine
particularly when we're still seeing
hundreds and hundreds of deaths from
chromovirus a day
in this associate professor of
epidemiology at the johns hopkins at
bloomberg school of public health
professor kerry altoff carey thanks so
much for your time always great to have
you on the show we should know that the
johns hopkins bloomberg school of public
health is supported by michael r
bloomberg
founder of bloomberg lp and bloomberg
philanthropies
well coming up next paul krugman shares
his predictions on the us economy
we'll be back in two minutes this is
quick take charge
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so this is the difference
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york
well with widespread optimism around u.s
economic recovery nobel laureate paul
krugman gave our friends at bloomberg tv
his perspective on the us economy
and a proposal from the biden
administration to double the capital
gains tax
here's what he predicts
i'm still not entirely sure that we've
got the pandemic
under control you know we think we've
got it but a little bit alarming
and look i i am um we are
they'll put this way larry summons is
not being completely uh
foolish here there is a it's a lot of
money that we're throwing at the economy
and uh
it could be it it could be a problem
although i think we have ways to deal
with it but
uh so we're giving a really big boost to
the to things right now i mean i'm very
optimistic but
but there's always some there's both
downside and upside risk
both both that you know pandemic hits us
again or
that this thing goes too fast and you
know we're starting to see bottlenecks
things uh there are a lot of problems
with with
a rapid recovery when we still have
disrupted supply chains so
this could be a no it's not going to be
totally smooth sailing well i am curious
when you look at the supply chains we've
been talking a lot about some of the
inflationary pressures
out there whether it's in some of the
commodities or now and some of the
consumer staples here
some of that of course is sort of tied
to uh the economy sort of reheating but
a lot of that is also tied here
to the disruptions that we had because
of covid and i'm wondering if maybe that
if we if you consider some of those
disruptions to be temporary that the
inflationary pressures might not be
as heavy as some people think
yeah i think it's going to be important
and i think people at the fed know this
that
core inflation is actually not a
sufficient a sufficient statistic here
uh
that even uh you know normally we think
that okay this transitory stuff is
basically food and energy
but now there's going to be transitory
shortage as well you know we have chips
uh lumber uh the uh there's a shortage
of containers uh so
there's a lot of sort of unusual
disruptions all of which is not
fundamental
uh all of which doesn't mean that we
actually are seeing an up
a rise in underlying inflation it just
means that we're hitting some
some bottlenecks as we come back from a
highly disrupted economy and stuff that
should be disregarded
in in terms of studying policy and so
don't we all have big buttons that say
don't panic
on the inflation front sending policy
from a monetary policy front there when
it comes to inflation when it comes to
labor data but
there's also of course what the
government is up to and
asset prices well maybe a bit of
inflation pressure took a leg
around today because they were worried
about capital gains taxes coming forward
what do you think about
the inevitability or not of tax
increases and what it means for the
overall economy
well yeah there's going to be i mean
that's a little bit weird right we had
uh
this is something that biden had said
all along he was going to
try to do and now he says i'm going to
try to do what i promised i was going to
do in the market
although yeah we get if if a 1 fall in
stock prices
is is all that you get from a really
major increase in capital gains taxes
that's
that's not a big problem um but yeah i
mean the
the biden has an ambitious agenda
um we have a some fiscal space interest
rates are extremely low
we have learned that debt fears are
exaggerated but we don't have infinite
fiscal space
so some significant tax increases
are going to be part of the story and
biden is trying to do those with
not hitting the middle class at all so
it's supposed to be
corporate taxes and then high taxes high
incomes
capital gains uh it's so but something
like that is is pretty much inevitable
unless
everything is you know fails
because still this stuff could still
stumble in congress it's possible still
that
that uh you know they they need all 50
senators but
plus kamala harris to pass any of this
stuff but but assuming that they're
going to get through with this stuff
they are going to need some taxes to pay
for at least part of it
and and that was economist paul krugman
speaking thursday with bloomberg's
romaine bostick and caroline hyde now
coming up u.s gymnast simone biles is
ending her contract with nike
and entering a new partnership with
athleta we've got all the details and
what it means for nike's future
as well as the as the power today's
athletes are wielding in the business
world we'll be back in two minutes
this is quick take charge
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenovec
and i'm jennifer zabasanja in new york
now to big news
shaking up both the sports world and the
business world this morning in a
surprise move
famed olympic gymnast simone biles is
leaving nike for a partnership
with athleta which athletic calls in a
press release
a shared vision designed to empower
women and girls
this comes days after nike's partnership
with kobe bryant's estate
expired and two years after allison
felix left nike for athleta after she
criticized nike
for failing to support pregnant athletes
so what does this all mean for nike and
is this a trend that we are going to
continue to see so
we are very excited to have both
bloomberg opinion columnist
sarah halzick join us from washington dc
and quick take chief correspondent
uh jason kelly joining us for this
discussion so sarah jason thank you both
for being here this is really a
fascinating story sarah we wanted to
start with you
how significant is this for athleta
to get a partnership with a massive
athlete like simone biles
this is huge athleta is still it's a
fast-growing brand but it's a relatively
small
brand in the athletic wear universe it
does about a billion in sales it's on
track for about 2 billion in sales
in 2023 but it's a cornerstone of gaps
growth strategy
as that chain's namesake brand and the
banana republic brand
kind of struggle to stay relevant it's
all about old navy and athleta to keep
uh
gap in good shape and this is like a
really
important step in that direction because
one of the challenges for athleta has
been how does it distinguish itself from
lululemon a competitor
that's really similar and firing on all
cylinders
and this will help it achieve that jason
come on in here
i was really struck by something that
simone biles told the wall street
journal
in her interview around this news she
said quote i felt like it wasn't just
about my achievements it's what i stood
for
and how they were going to help me use
my voice and also be a voice for female
athletes and kids
i feel like they also support me not
just as an athlete but as an individual
outside of the gym and the change that i
want to create
which is so refreshing jason you've
covered the business of sports for years
i'm wondering how this symbolizes the
different way that athletes are feeling
about the types of companies that
they're aligning themselves with
and also how they want to push for
change
outside of what they're doing
professionally for the greater society
well tim i think that comment that
simone miles files made is
a very 2021 sentiment and it's
interesting you know she's signing this
deal
when she's 24 she was 18 i believe when
she signed with nike
those intervening six years for her as
an athlete for her as a businesswoman
in many ways for the world at large and
what athletes stand for
massive things have changed and i think
it symbolizes a lot
about the power that athletes are taking
back in terms of literally and
figuratively
owning their own brands and deciding who
they want to be
both as she has said in the gym and and
outside
so they are voting with their feet and
ultimately
you know with the dollars that they
carry with them and and the markets and
and the audiences that they have jason
do you think this is something we're
going to continue seeing i mean
you know you've spoken to a number of
athletes um is
is this the way that they are headed
100 i mean i i can't tell you if you saw
my inbox and the pictures that i get
almost every day about
you know this athlete investing here you
know whether it's
the sort of obvious well-known examples
like lebron james
or aaron rodgers or you know you look at
what sue bird and megan rapino have been
doing in both
speaking out and i know that's a story
you followed closely jen you know
this is a new era in many ways and it is
this sense of
ownership in all senses of the word both
the financial aspect of it
but also the the symbolic aspect of it
and i think it's only going to continue
and as i talk to even younger athletes
high school college athletes they're
thinking along these lines
this is the business they want to be in
uh
as they continue their careers and
beyond hey sarah how big of a loss is
this
for nike uh this is a company that in
recent years has struggled with
news reports about the way that it
treats female employees and
also female athletes athletes who have
gotten pregnant
while they've been under contract from
nike as the wall street journal points
out and has been widely reported
how big of a loss is this for nike's
brand
so i don't think it's that big of a loss
from a dollar standpoint
you know nike still has a real
murderer's row of sponsored athletes
but i do think the optics of this are
not good for nike as you point out
they've had
this steady trickle of headlines about
their treatment of
female athletes and about their
workplace culture being toxic for women
and here you have this really high
profile athlete whose
you know powers are going to be on full
display this summer at the tokyo games
um and she has defected to go to a much
smaller brand so
yeah i don't think um the optics are
good for nike and
you know to jason's earlier points i i
think that this
belies not just where athletes are but
where young consumers
are right now this idea to sort of
have align yourself with brands that are
consistent with your values we see this
with the way that many gen z folks are
shopping
um and so it's not surprising to me that
gen z and young millennial athletes are
operating this way too
and sarah i mean nike put out a
statement wishing simone the best but
saying that
they plan to continue to evolve and
support female athletes i mean
what what do you think is their next
move i mean you mentioned
they're going to be on full display this
summer but um you know how how do they
win back these young consumers
yeah so i think that they continue to uh
build they're really trying to put a lot
of energy behind
their women's business behind making the
garments and sneakers aimed at women
uh you know fine-tuning that business
and making those garments better and i
think that will help
they've also taken steps like um you
know nike only just recently added
maternity workout wear
that was something they didn't even
offer that other competitors have had
for quite some time so i think those are
subtle signals to women
that they are really trying to design
for their lifestyle and for for them for
the unique needs of them as athletes
hey jason when are these companies going
to really
feel like they're starting to lead when
it comes to these things and not
necessarily follow the lead of athletes
here
it certainly feels like uh these
companies
obviously are huge and the
decision-making process is a long time
but
increasingly like you explored with your
with your business of sports
uh special that took place in georgia um
the way that
that individuals and sports teams want
to lead here
um how do you see companies doing this
i think companies realize they need the
athletes in a much more meaningful way i
mean
it's a it's a term that's thrown around
and i'm sure sarah and i would both
and all of you as journalists would sort
of roll your eyes we all roll our eyes
when we hear about well this is a
partnership
i i actually think it does have to be a
much more
intimate relationship you know between
these athletes and
the companies because as demonstrated by
this simone biles news
they'll walk you know like that they
have they feel
much more emboldened it used to be
something where this was only in the nba
or the wnba you know those were the
examples of player activism
and and real power this is now extending
across the entire sports landscape
across
all sorts of sports and all ages as we
talked about earlier so
i think companies need to get religion
on the fact that these athletes have
power
that is not going away and platforms
that they are very willing to use
bloomberg sarah halzak and jason kelly a
big thank you to both of you
for your time well sticking with sports
portland
trail blazers center ines cantor is
consistently using his platform to speak
out on social justice and human rights
issues
cantor knows that there is still a long
fight ahead for equality and urges that
quote
we need unity more than anything else
our vanessa perdomo caught up with
cantor
check it out
so the last time we spoke was right
after nba players protested games
due to the police shooting of jacob lake
and we just saw
derek chovin was found guilty for
murdering george floyd which is another
police shooting that
nba players were really outspoken
against what is the feeling like amongst
players in the league right now after
this
guilty verdict was announced well you
know
like everyone else obviously i followed
the derek children trial like most of
the
country not just the mba players but
most of the country
you know just a friend and for justice
for george floyd and obviously
um jury you know found them guilty on
all three
accounts you know manslaughter and
murder
but uh you know they made the decision
pretty
swiftly and the facts were all there and
the evidence was all there
and the powerful video uh the whole
world saw
and we can finally say that
justice was a serve and i think it's a
huge step forward for
you know the social adjustment equality
and
you know i believe uh you know we need
to remember that that is only just
uh one case of uh so so
many you know and you know it begs the
question you know
if it were not for that video would we
have this
kind of a sort of justice you know
and so it is what it takes so i believe
you know black lives always matter no
matter what
so yes i feel like this was a huge step
forward but
i feel like we need to we need to make a
systematic
change and as everyone says and everyone
knows and all them paper
players saying that we have a long fight
ahead of us so we just need to
keep uh pushing and just uh and try to
inspire our young
generation as much as we can how do you
push forward
to make sure that this isn't just a
one-off case that this does continue
to be the verdict if you're an athlete
actor singer rapper or you know if you
have a platform i feel like we need to
use this platform to inspire as many
people we can especially our young
generation the other thing is uh for
sure you know just
there there is a bill out there called
george uh foster
bill and other other things that we we
definitely should
uh push our politicians
senators congressmen congresswomans to
you know just
talk about these issues more and more
because this is only
one case there are so many cases out
there uh
you know so that that's why i feel like
we need to use our
platform to try to spot as much as we
can
and you do use your platform more than a
lot of people do you're a huge advocate
for human rights
one of the things that you just teamed
up with israeli ambassador gilad erdogan
on a op-ed for against anti-semitism
can you tell me how that partnership
came to be and why as someone who's not
jewish you still felt compelled to speak
on this issue and when i
met with ambassador guillerm obviously
he's a huge
basketball fan i met him this last
last summer in new york me and him
sit down had an amazing conversation and
uh
you know i was like it doesn't matter
what your religion is your background or
your
your skin color or your whatever you are
you know the most important thing in
life is leave your difference on the
table and try to find what we have in
common
because we only have one world to live
you know
and so i was like let's let's bring our
powers together
and try to bring uh you know awareness
of where what's going on
not just anti-semitism but phobia and
and all the other issues around the
world because i feel like we need
unity more than everything you know so
that's why he's in big basketball and by
the way he came to our game in
miami down to miami and he had an
amazing time so
i'm glad that i have a friend like him
absolutely and speaking of unity in that
way
he's a politician and you're a
professional athlete worlds that
necessarily
a lot of people wouldn't think collide
because politics does
divide a lot of people and sports is
seen as something to bring people
together
so do you think that colliding those
worlds is even more powerful
in the message of unity of course
obviously you know because
i mean uh i feel like you know he has a
huge uh
following and obviously i have a huge
following because of the nba
platform so i feel like bring those
powers together is definitely creating
more awareness
you know he is a jewish ambassador and a
muslim athlete so when this two
person comes together to to to talk
about unity talk about uh islamophobia
to talk about anti-semitism talk about
what can we do to bring more you know
peace and love
and fight against hate you know people
just stops and say wow this is very
unique we never
we've never seen this kind of
collaboration before so i think it's you
know it's
it's all about you know uh fighting for
uh
one thing and it's uh it's the
fight against hate ennis thanks so much
for joining us
and we'll continue to look for what you
and other athletes do
to help bring social justice issues
forward thank you honestly i appreciate
it
and that was portland trailblazers
center ennis cantor speaking with r
vanessa perdomo coming up
spacex has successfully sent astronauts
into space on a rocket that's already
been used
we'll discuss what this means for the
future of space travel in two minutes
this is quick take charge
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
four three
pretty cool stuff there hey welcome back
to quick take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja
and i'm tim stenovec in new york well
there you see four astronauts
beginning their cruise to the
international space station aboard a
spacex capital in the capsule in the
company's
first crude trip this one with a
reusable
rocket spacex has championed the goal of
designing spacecraft for multiple
missions as the only practical and
economical method to lower launch costs
and expand human
exploration specifically to mars with us
now from san francisco is bloomberg's ed
ludlow ed
it's so great to have you on the show to
talk about this i gotta say
to our viewers to everyone watching you
pulled an all-nighter to make this
happen so we really appreciate that
um how big of a step forward is this for
spacex
given that it's it's able to use uh
these
recycled materials these these actual
recycled products
uh to uh to to to head to the space
station how big of a step is it for the
company and for the us space program
yeah that's really the point here
because it's not the first time
obviously that spacex has carried human
beings to international space station we
had the demo in may of last year
and then the first crew dragon team went
up soon after that
it was the first time that spacex
carried humans recycling both the
capsule
crew dragon the thing that the
astronauts actually sit in and the
falcon 9 rocket the booster
which propels it at launch um and it's
you know actually a question of
economics you know back when nasa relied
on the shuttle program
it was at a cost of hundreds of millions
of dollars per launch and really what
spacex has been able to do
by by reusing both the booster the
rocket and the capsule
is dramatically reduce the cost for nasa
to get human beings and supplies
and you know running supply maintenance
missions to international space station
which means they're more frequent we're
seeing people go up into space
more frequently humans in orbit more
frequently and as one astronaut put it
yesterday just before launch this is the
golden age of space travel that really
is the significance of
of friday's launch and ed i mean as tim
mentioned
you were up all night sort of covering
the story what was it like for you
to watch it this morning with with the
rest of the world i mean
what what was your reaction to it yeah
it's an interesting experience i would
urge viewers to go back on youtube and
what
relax watch the launch not just that one
but the crew one launch
as well because you can follow the
chronology the series of events
you know the first thing that happens is
launch of course then after about 60
seconds
the rocket reaches max q that's when the
rocket's under the most stress that it
will be
the thrusters go to max we're traveling
at supersonic speed
about 90 seconds later the first stage
of the rocket separates from the second
stage and crew dragon carries on
using a secondary booster a few minutes
later after that
it separates from the secondary boost of
the capsule and at that point
the capsule is 200 kilometers above
earth and and
starts to conduct this series of
complicated maneuvers but there are
risks
along the way if you listen to ground
control
they will give call signs and
announcements for the different abort
zones that's the opportunity
that the dragon capsule has to disengage
to remove itself from the boosters in
the event of emergency and it also has
those three parachutes as well but it
but it's tense
and on the other side you know i'm a
journalist i want to be objective
but it's just i'm a huge space romantic
this is exciting
i like rockets i like spiders i like
star wars films who doesn't
and really you know it's completely fair
to say that what spacex and nasa have
done
excuse me over the last six months is
they've captured the imagination not
just to people in north america
but globally about what's possible
because this is the first time in a
decade
that we've launched humans from a u.s
launch
site the first time ever that that a u.s
agency has carried
esa the european space agency and japan
agency
uh astronauts since they shut down the
shuttle
program so we've come a long way ed i
should note that you know you say you
say romantic i
describe myself as a nerd i much prefer
the way that you describe it as a space
romantic
you know i think back though ed you know
i've been following spacex for years and
if we think back to just a few years ago
the company made history with a rocket
that landed
on the drone ship that's become routine
at this point
it's not even a big deal when the
company does that anymore
when does this not become a big deal
when is it routine to just use recycled
spacecraft to send people to the iss and
beyond
well without something boring there is
some some regulatory considerations
right so the
the crew dragon the capsule is certified
for five flights
so the so so it has a maximum life now
elon musk was speaking on friday morning
about the falcon 9 in particular the
booster the actual rocket
and about how many times it can be
reused and
the the short answer is that they will
just keep reusing it
until it no longer works but not using
humans
as the test for that that's too risky
spacex is also working on starlink right
that
is it's a network of low orbit
satellites that provide
internet connection to people around the
world and they use the same falcon 9
booster
rocket for that as they do for the human
launches so they're basically saying
what we can do is use them
until they no longer work but remember
when spacex was founded in 2002 which
seems a long time ago now
it was with the goal of putting humans
onto other planets
i'm talking about mars so this is
incredibly exciting
and we are being a little bit futuristic
but elon musk and spacex are looking
well past
supply missions and rotation of
astronauts to iss
they're already thinking about mars and
populating
the human species on other planets and
when they're able to do that with
starship the next generation of rocket
that's really when this becomes
a little redundant all right we're gonna
have to leave it there
uh space romantic bloomberg's ed ludlow
who hasn't slept at all
but is the perfect person to speak to
about this this morning ed ludlow thanks
so much hopefully you get some sleep but
we really appreciate your time
and coming up some good news about
investments made on earth day
we'll be back in two minutes this is
quick take charge
access the financial world
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is our generation's biggest problem
climate change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change in
the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim steineveck
and i'm jennifer zabasaja in new york
let's look at some developing stories we
are tracking
this morning so in ukraine russia
is starting to withdraw thousands of
troops from areas near the ukrainian
border today ukraine
says it welcomes a move in that it
reduces tension
western leaders had called on moscow to
pull the troops back
there were fears the conflict could lead
to new economic
sanctions and in china
and in china president xi jinping's next
target in the tech crackdown is the
country's
vast streams of data china is forecast
to hold
about a third of the world's data by
2025. last month she promised to go
after platform companies that amassed
data to create monopolies
and gobble up smaller competitors and
finally in
london climate activists continued a
series of protests on friday morning
dumping a pile of fake coal outside the
lloyds of london
building blocking the entrance the
insurance rebellion group accused
lloyd's insurers of fueling climate
change by supporting fossil fuel
projects
including the adani carmichael coal mine
in australia
lloyds has said it will stop ensuring
coal oil sands and arctic energy
projects
by 2030. activists activists also
defaced
property of hsbc in london yesterday
and you can get and you can get caught
up on all the day's news at
bloomberg.com or quicktake on social
media
well now it's time for some quick take
good news on this friday morning
thursday was earth day and investors
celebrated by pouring a record amount of
money
into a carbon market fund that punishes
polluters
the crane shares global carbon etf had
inflows of more than 15
million dollars on thursday bringing its
total assets to more than
160 million that's according to some
bloomberg data
it's the largest publicly traded fund
that invests in cap and trade systems
that put an added price on
burning fossil fuels on the day more
than 20 world leaders met at biden's
virtual climate summit european union
carbon futures surged to a record
exceeding more than 56.68 cents per
metric ton
it's a gain of almost 90 since the start
of 2020.
they are slightly down as of this
morning that's going to do it for quick
take this hour but there's much more
quick take coming up in
just a minute i'm tim stenovich and i'm
jennifer zabasanja you can check out all
of these stories
at bloomberg
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
quick take charge where we bring you
today's top news and break down how it
intersects with the world of business
i'm tim stenovich and i'm jennifer's
abisage in new york it's friday april
23rd we have a lot to get to so let's
get going
good morning everyone and happy friday
let's start though with bitcoin
which is not having so great of a friday
heading for its worst week in more than
a year
the world's largest digital currency
extended losses after president biden
proposed almost
doubling the capital gains tax for those
who make a million dollars or more a
year
and it said investors rushing to get out
well they could and
sell their bitcoin resulting in the
biggest drop in stocks in more than a
month
here to break down why this matters to
retail investors is the ceo of the
fintech company skilling michael cameron
and also bloomberg's wall street
reporter shinali basic a big thank you
to both of you for
being here chanel i want to start with
you um why does a tax proposal
aimed at just the top three tenths of
one percent have such a dramatic effect
on the stock market well it's amazing
tim because you have the situation where
wealthy people are the folks that engage
most
in the stock market so that's by means
of you know their own personal trading
their their own accounts but it's also
by means of family offices as we know
right now
so that's one thing but it's more uh
smoke than fire right i mean there's
this you say tax and it's like the
market freaks out
uh mike novogratz who we interview on
this program um you know quite
frequently
at bloomberg he has been warning of this
for many many months right before the
election even started that
we can expect more uh capital gains i
mean the president himself was warning
about this during his campaign like this
didn't come out of nowhere
no surprise how and especially because
you know frankly
what we are talking about now is more
contained than many on wall street even
believed would be happening
but i think what's happening now is the
fact that it's becoming closer
to reality that's spooking people uh a
little bit and what the ramifications
might be of it and michael
how much do you read into this news and
how does the retail investor sort of
interpret
everything that has happened this past
week i
i don't think that it's going to be a
long-term drag on
on the the price of bitcoin and i don't
think that retail traders are going to
see
a lot of uh they're not going to see it
as an impediment to long-term price
change like long-term price growth
so for for you know from my perspective
i don't think it's going to be a
long-term drag
for clients um michael talk a little bit
about why we're seeing the
drag on coins that we've seen right
right this week i mean over the weekend
there was some
concern about regulation that didn't end
up
coming to fruition or at least we didn't
even get more details about that
uh but but why are we seeing a bitcoin
headed for its its worst week in a month
i think it's a classic
uh buy the rumor sell the news so i
think there was a lot of uh
a lot of the the smart money on bitcoin
uh
specifically bitcoin was watching the
coinbase ipo and in the weeks and months
leading up to it knew that would be a
watershed moment
for the industry and then more
specifically for bitcoin so they were
you know increasingly
getting involved in in bitcoin and then
as soon as the ipo hit
that's when the news came out so i think
it was a very stereotypical buy the
rumor cell to
sell the news story and um i think that
has a lot to do a lot to do with it and
some profit taking but i don't think
it's
i think that for all the bitcoin
enthusiasts and hardcore you know uh
bitcoin traders it's it's just going to
be another leg down before another leg
up and a lot of their opinions
chanel how are your sources on on wall
street reacting
right that whole buy the rumor sell the
news thing is a real thing right i mean
there's something about this that people
like dips right it's where they
buy the most but even beyond that
something interesting about uh crypto
that i wanted to point out
and i'm stealing a note here from
bloomberg opinions brian chapata who who
makes this point
you know bitcoin if you tax it what
makes it harder for people
is that it makes it harder as a form of
payment
right and that's where people want to
see more adoption and payment i'm really
curious about what michael thinks about
this too
because you know we did see news this
week jen we saw news
you know wework for example warming up
to cryptocurrencies
and i've been wondering all year you
know what is the marginal value of more
companies getting
uh getting in on crypto what is the
marginal value of more big crypto news
because we've seen such a run-up this
year
already um you know what is the next big
thing to happen in crypto that will give
um you know the prices another leg up
michael do you have that i can speak for
them i can speak from our perspective we
you know we see a lot of requests for
you know we you know in our industry in
online trading we see a lot of requests
for
funding accounts uh with with
cryptocurrencies and it's still not
widely
widely used in our industry uh there's
still kind of a lot of the
the stereotypical concerns that that uh
financial institutions have always had
about cryptocurrencies but as as big
names like paypal
and venmo move into these spaces and as
coinbase
has now gone public and is likely the
first of many
uh and there's you know reporting
requirements and good governance
requirements there i think that the the
payment space is going to see a lot of
shake up with crypto i think payments is
going to
going to start piercing into markets
where they're not you know it's not
really that common
so you know we're seeing it in our
industry we're seeing a lot of clients
say
hey i'd like to fund i i know i can fund
via you know the the typical methods
but i've got cryptocurrencies especially
since there's been a big run-up in price
i'd like to take advantage of that
yeah can i fund those and i think that's
going to grow hey michael i i
i want to ask about the idea and and
chanally mention this the idea of
more and more companies starting to
accept cryptocurrency as a payment the
wework news of course that you talked
about
uh and then also venmo and and paypal
paypal's been doing this for months at
this point
um but tesla uh just a few months ago um
and then of course what microstrategy
has been doing for a long time with
adding
cryptocurrency and bitcoin specifically
to its balance sheet i posed this
question though to the ceo of chipotle
yesterday uh who we interviewed on
bloomberg businessweek radio to ask him
if if they have any plans to start
accepting bitcoin
and he really he pretty much laughed me
off with that with the question like
you know like no it's not it's something
that they've talked about but they have
no plans to do that
and they certainly have no plans to add
bitcoin to their balance sheet um if
if we don't see widespread adoption of
actually accepting it
as a currency is is there a limit to how
high it goes
i think that's a very uh i think that's
i think that's a wrong way to look at it
so we operate in our in our industry we
operate in a very international space so
we don't we don't have we don't we don't
we don't have american customers number
one but we have customers from all over
the world
and um you know within western europe
and the united states and canada
the forms of payment methods are very
they're great they're highly developed
they're quick
but in other parts of the world there's
a there's a real use case
for being able to move your money around
and it being accepted as a form of
payment
so i think that for a company like
chipotle i'm you know i'm a customer
they're a great company
but they uh you know they don't they
probably don't have that that
as large as international customer base
as companies in my industry do
so we have a real need for customers
have a real need and desire to do that
and i think that i think this is only i
think if you laugh it out of the room i
think that
i think the time the history is not on
your side i think this is a wave that's
coming you i think you have to adopt it
there's ways to adopt it in manners that
will
jive with uh with what the typical
financial institutions are looking for
so there's
a real growing contingent of companies
that are
answering the questions that these
institutions have specifically around
anti-money laundering and
monitoring transactions that are maybe
nefarious there's ways now to track that
and there's ways to monitor those things
that are
you know widely used by law enforcement
agencies government agencies etc so
i think that's the wrong tack to take i
think that i think you need to be
accepting of these new technologies
and so then michael how are you advising
your customers about sort of what snacks
and what they should be paying attention
to
in terms of payments or in terms of
which cryptocurrencies are moving
which cryptocurrencies are moving so we
we offer uh one of the widest varieties
of cryptos in our in our space so we
offer 22 cryptocurrency products
we are we don't do any advising we don't
tell people to buy this or sell that we
leave that to the customer base we
we support a retail customer base like i
said from all over the world
and um and we leave it up to them but we
actively monitor what people are looking
for and what they're talking to us about
so if if today polka dot is rising and
tomorrow it's bitcoin cash and monday
it's dogecoin
um we're actively following that and
putting it on our platform so that if
customers want to find these things that
it's
they're easily accessible hey michael
you know i do want to kind of bring this
back into the tax conversation because i
feel like it's a really important one
especially because it's not something
that's going to be imminent it's going
to be a big ugly fight in washington
and it will probably create more
volatility as that goes along
what does what do these tax changes
have directly in terms of
um bitcoin prices and also adoption of
bitcoin
as people look for it as a payment
method
i i don't i don't think it's going to
have the impact
the the long-term impact that i think
that we're discussing here today i
i think that this is a bitcoin is
not a uniquely american product i think
that this this tax conundrum that we may
find ourselves in will have a short-term
blip on some of the larger
uh family from some of the family
offices some of the high net worth
individuals and when they buy
in the way they they view this as an
investment um but
the rest of the world i don't think
there's going to be a high correlation
to
you know that dragging on the price long
term i think that international
investors
will read the story find interest in it
but are not it's not going to act as a
drag so i don't think it's going to have
the long-term impact
that uh that that some think it may
michael cameron ceo of
skilling companies skilling and
bloomberg shinali basic
big thank you to both of you for your
time now we don't want to bury the lead
on the rest of the morning's top news so
here are some stories we do not want you
to miss
well it's day two of president biden's
virtual climate summit the goal was to
send the message that the u.s
is back and ready to lead many of the 40
heads of state taking part had their own
message for america
prove it president biden announced a new
commitment to reduce emissions but the
50
cut below 2005 levels may not even be
compatible with the paris climate
agreement
and u.s vaccine experts meet today to
review johnson and johnson's coronavirus
shot
it's been on hold for 10 days after
several cases of rare and serious blood
clots
the panel of experts advises the cdc the
15 voting members will debate whether
the shot should be used again
in the u.s and japanese tire maker
bridgestone
says it will support the tokyo olympics
and paralympic games is a key sponsor
as long as the safety of participants is
secured in an interview with bloomberg
ceo shushi ishibashi said that it will
refrain from holding a big marketing
campaign and
won't invite overseas guests you can
always learn more about these stories
and stay up to date on today's news at
bloomberg.com
and coming up black americans have died
at twice the rate
of white americans due to covet 19 and
yet the vaccine gap remains
in most of the us so how do we narrow it
we're talking to a professor of
epidemiology
next we'll be back in two minutes this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york well it's time now for quick take
by the numbers it's where we give you
the numbers that
tell the story this morning's number is
seven only seven states in the u.s have
cut their black vaccine gap in half
that's according to data from the
bloomberg vaccine tracker which tracks
data from 44 states and washington dc
and cities as well but now that almost
all adults in the u.s are eligible for
covered vaccines
the racial and ethnic disparities in
who's getting shots are
narrowing it's especially true in
alabama louisiana maryland mississippi
and north carolina
where black vaccine gaps have narrowed
from 10 points or more
to between 2.7 and 6.4 points
idaho and oregon have also improved
their gaps by
more than half though had much greater
equity to start
overall states are still lagging and
vaccinating black and hispanic people
despite a greater supply of vaccines and
few eligibility requirements a dozen
states have vaccinated 25
or more of their black population and
only nine have
done as well with hispanic people almost
every place we track
has done at least as well with white
people with a handful of states that
have vaccinated almost half
of their white populations
joining us now to discuss how the u.s
can target these populations
is associate professor of epidemiology
at the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health kerry
altoff
carey thanks so much for being with us
this morning so you know as you as you
mentioned as we've talked about
we were able to target older adults
getting vaccinated early on
why aren't we able to do the same with
minority communities
so older adults did have a pretty steep
barrier technologically wise in some
communities in order to access those
vaccine appointments
but the barriers for accessing vaccine
for black and latino communities
they can be very very different in
addition to perhaps some technology gaps
that could occur there
there's also work people are working
people need access to vaccine
from specific areas that are close to
them
and and walk-up options they also need
it in their communities if it's too
far for them to access when we see these
gaps
in terms of the even just looking at the
proportion of black and latino americans
and that they're lagging behind that
tells us right there we need to do more
to get the vaccine
to them so it is about reducing those
barriers it's also about the messenger
which is a really important part of this
it's about ensuring that trust
that individuals can go into the
communities
we can work with those community
partners churches
community organizations to help us pull
people together to get the vaccine but
it should be also noted
that in a number of recent polls we have
not seen
vaccine hesitancy rates extraordinarily
high in black americans as compared to
right
yeah i think that's a really good point
because it goes against the narrative
that emerged at the beginning of this
which was that there was a more
hesitancy among certain demographics of
people in the united states and it's
turning out not necessarily to be the
case dr althoff as you point out
a lot of it has to do with access and
i'm wondering what specific steps can be
taken to
improve that access here in new york for
example they're starting to do
walk-in appointments for some residents
depending on whether or not you
uh qualify among certain criteria
certain age groups
i'm wondering if that's the way to do it
because then you don't have to worry
about making that appointment you don't
have to
worry about finding that time that
actually works you don't have to stay up
late trying to find that slot in a in a
place that is close to where you live
absolutely walk-ins are essential but
then it's also making sure that you have
the staff
and the vaccine supply so that those
weights are not
incredibly long because people will come
after work
on the weekend during these different
times when they have a chance but
nobody has the time then to wait in line
for three hours for that appointment so
it is about walk-ins it's also about
making sure
that those walk-in locations are located
to where people can access them
and that they are fully staffed and have
ample vaccine supply it's also about
putting
vaccine on vans and driving into
communities if you cannot get
a site set up right there it's also
about engaging with employers especially
large-scale employers to think about how
vaccination
could be brought into the workplace and
carrie i mean at the same time as we're
talking about this the ap this morning
has a story out saying
that louisiana and some other southern
states have had
have asked the federal government to cut
back on how much
vaccine shipments they are getting
because of um
the decrease in demand that there is so
how concerning
is that for you especially given what
you're saying you know
um that we still need to get these
populations vaccinated
and we're hearing that you know there
are some states that are asking for
smaller shipments at this point in time
so we knew this point
would come at some point where we have
met the demand and then the supply would
exceed the demand
and really we're in in a place in some
states where and in some locations in
states
where there are individuals where
there's greater vaccine hesitancy there
was a
recent poll out that looked at more
rural white americans expressing
more vaccine hesitancy and saying we
will not be vaccinated unless forced to
and so this is one of those situations
where um
thinking through instead of just saying
hold on the vaccine it's thinking
through okay
who are the right messengers to go in
and explore
why there's so much vaccine hesitancy
what information and communication is
needed because at the end of the day
just like we're seeing not only
in our rural areas in our urban areas
all across
america it's going to take everyone to
build
sufficient immunity in the us as well as
worldwide
professor altof as we mentioned earlier
in the show vaccine experts meet today
to review johnson johnson's shot it has
been on hold
for 10 days i wonder to what extent the
single shot from j and j plays
into getting these next portion of
americans vaccinated because
with that shot you are one and done
absolutely um it's also a shot that can
can travel
pretty well can go on in the communities
so there are a lot of
a lot of really good things the
important part
about what we're doing with this j j
vaccine right now
is that we are digging deeply into the
safety we are anxious to hear what acip
says today particularly if there are any
new cases that have been discovered that
should be presented today
we should have a full understanding i
think most scientists anticipate the
vaccine will be put back into use due to
just
how rare this blood clotting situation
is
but there may be important
recommendations guidelines different
things for clinicians and public health
workers to understand about who maybe
should not
be vaccinated with this type of vaccine
it is also about rebuilding that
confidence that i think we have lost a
bit
to say you know what yes there are side
effects this is one we fully
investigated here is the benefit to this
vaccine particularly when we're still
seeing
hundreds and hundreds of deaths from
chronovirus a day
in this country associate professor of
epidemiology at the johns hopkins at
bloomberg school of public health
professor kerry altoff carrie thanks so
much for your time always great to have
you on the show we should know that the
johns hopkins bloomberg school of public
health is supported by michael r
bloomberg
founder of bloomberg lp and bloomberg
philanthropies
well coming up next paul krugman shares
his predictions on the u.s economy
we'll be back in two minutes this is
quick charge
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
the differences
[Music]
welcome back to take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york
well with widespread optimism around u.s
economic recovery nobel laureate paul
krugman
gave our friends at bloomberg tv his
perspective on the us economy
and a proposal from the biden
administration to double the capital
gains tax
here's what he predicts
i'm still not entirely sure that we've
got the pandemic
under control you know we think we've
got it but a little bit alarming
and look i i am um we are
we'll put this way larry summons is not
being completely
uh foolish here there is a it's a lot of
money that we're throwing at the economy
and uh
it could be it could be a problem
although i think we have ways to deal
with it but
uh so we're giving a really big boost to
the to things right now i mean i'm very
optimistic but
but there's always some there's both
downside and upside risk
both both that you know pandemic hits us
again or
that this thing goes too fast and you
know we're starting to see bottlenecks
things uh there are a lot of problems
with with uh
rapid recovery when we still have
disrupted supply chains so
this could be a no it's not going to be
totally smooth sailing well i am curious
when you look at the supply chains we've
been talking a lot about some of the
inflationary pressures
out there whether it's in some of the
commodities or now and some of the
consumer staples here
some of that of course is sort of tied
to uh the economy sort of reheating but
a lot of that is also tied here
to the disruptions that we had because
of covid and i'm wondering if maybe that
uh if we if you consider some of those
disruptions to be temporary
that the inflationary pressures might
not be as heavy as some people think
yeah i think it's going to be important
and i think the people at the fed know
this that
core inflation is actually not a
sufficient a sufficient statistic here
that even you know normally we think
that okay this transitory stuff is
basically food and energy
but now there's going to be transitory
shortage as well you know we have uh
chips
uh lumber uh the uh there's a shortage
of containers
uh so there's a lot of sort of unusual
disruptions all of which is not
fundamental all of which doesn't mean
that we actually are seeing an
up a rise in underlying inflation it
just means that we're hitting some
some bottlenecks as we come back from a
highly disrupted economy and stuff that
should be disregarded
in in terms of setting policy and so
don't we all have big buttons that say
don't panic uh
on the inflation front selling policy
from a monetary policy front there when
it comes to inflation when it comes to
labor data but
there's also of course what the
government is up to and
asset prices well maybe a bit of
inflation pressure took a leg around
today because they were worried about
capital gains taxes coming forward what
do you think about
the inevitability or not of tax
increases and what it means for the
overall economy
well yeah there's going to be i mean
that's a little bit weird right we had
uh
this is something that biden had said
all along he was going to
try to do and now he says i'm going to
try to do what i promised i was going to
do in the market
although we get if a one percent fall in
stock prices
is is all that you get from a really
major increase in capital gains taxes
that's
that's not a big problem um but yeah i
mean the
the biden has an ambitious agenda
um we have a some fiscal space interest
rates are extremely low
we have learned that debt fears are
exaggerated but we don't have infinite
fiscal space
so some significant tax increases
are going to be part of the story and
biden is trying to do those with
not hitting the middle class at all so
it's supposed to be
corporate taxes and then high taxes high
incomes
capital gains uh it's so but something
like that is is pretty much inevitable
unless
everything is you know fails
because still this stuff could still
stumble in congress it's possible still
that
that uh you know they they need all 50
senators but
plus kamala harris to pass any of this
stuff but but assuming that they're
going to get through with this stuff
they are going to need some taxes to pay
for at least part of it
and and that was economist paul krugman
speaking thursday with bloomberg's
romaine bostick and caroline hyde now
coming up u.s gymnast simone biles is
ending her contract with nike
and entering a new partnership with
athleta we've got all the details and
what it means for nike's future
as well as the as the power today's
athletes are wielding in the business
world we'll be back in two minutes
this is quick take charge
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim stenovec
and i'm jennifer zabasanja in new york
now to big news
shaking up both the sports worlds and
the business world this morning in a
surprise move
famed olympic gymnast simone biles is
leaving nike for a partnership
with athleta which athletic calls in a
press release
a shared vision designed to empower
women and girls
this comes days after nike's partnership
with kobe bryant's estate expired
and two years after allison felix left
nike for athleta after she criticized
nike
for failing to support pregnant athletes
so what does this all mean for nike and
is this a trend that we are going to
continue to see
so we are very excited to have both
bloomberg opinion columnist
sarah halzick join us from washington dc
and quick take chief correspondent
jason kelly joining us for this
discussion so sarah jason thank you both
for being here this is really a
fascinating story sarah we wanted to
start with you
how significant is this for athleta
to get a partnership with a massive
athlete like simone biles
this is huge athleta is still it's a
fast-growing brand but it's a relatively
small
brand in the athletic wear universe it
does about a billion in sales it's on
track for about 2 billion in sales
in 2023 but it's a cornerstone of gap's
growth strategy
as that chain's namesake brand and the
banana republic brand
kind of struggle to stay relevant it's
all about old navy and athleta to keep
uh gap in good shape and this is like a
really important step
in that direction because one of the
challenges for athleta has been
how does it distinguish itself from
lululemon a competitor
that's really similar and firing on all
cylinders
and this will help it achieve that jason
come on in here i was really struck by
something that simone biles told the
wall street journal in her interview
around this news she said quote i felt
like it wasn't just about my
achievements it's
what i stood for and how they were going
to help me use my voice and also be a
voice for female athletes and kids i
feel like they also support me not just
as an athlete
but as an individual outside of the gym
and the change that i want to create
which is so refreshing jason you've
covered the business of sports for years
i'm wondering how this symbolizes the
different way that athletes are feeling
about the types of companies that
they're aligning themselves with
and also how they want to push for
change uh
outside of what they're doing
professionally for the greater society
well tim i think that comment that
simone miles viles made is
a very 2021 sentiment and it's
interesting you know she's signing this
deal
when she's 24 she was 18 i believe when
she signed with nike
those intervening six years for her as
an athlete for her as a businesswoman
in many ways for the world at large and
what athletes stand for
massive things have changed and i think
it symbolizes a lot
about the power that athletes are taking
back in terms of literally and
figuratively
owning their own brands and deciding who
they want to be
both as she has said in the gym and and
outside
so they are voting with their feet and
ultimately
you know with the dollars that they
carry with them and and the markets and
and the audiences
that they have jason do you think this
is something we're going to continue
seeing i mean you know you've spoken to
a number of athletes
um is is this the way that they are
headed
100 i mean i i can't tell you if you saw
my inbox and the pictures that i get
almost every day about
you know this athlete investing here you
know whether it's
the sort of obvious well-known examples
like lebron james or aaron rodgers or
you know you look at what sue bird and
megan rapino have been doing in in both
speaking out and i know that's a story
you followed closely jen
you know this is a new era in many ways
and it
is this sense of ownership in all senses
of the word both the financial aspect of
it
but also the the symbolic aspect of it
and i think it's only going to continue
and as i talk to even younger athletes
high school college athletes they're
thinking along these lines
this is the business they want to be in
uh as they continue their careers
and beyond hey sarah how big of a loss
is this for nike
uh this is a company that in recent
years has struggled with
news reports about the way that it
treats female employees and
also female athletes athletes who have
gotten pregnant
while they've been under contract from
nike as the wall street journal points
out and has been widely reported
how big of a loss is this for nike's
brand
so i don't think it's that big of a loss
from a dollar standpoint
you know nike still has a real
murderer's row of sponsored athletes
but i do think the optics of this are
not good for nike as you point out
they've had
this steady trickle of headlines about
their treatment of
female athletes and about their
workplace culture being toxic for women
and here you have this really high
profile athlete whose
you know powers are going to be on full
display this summer at the tokyo games
um and she has defected to go to a much
smaller brand
so yeah i i don't think um the optics
are good for nike and
you know to jason's earlier points i i
think that this
belies not just where athletes are but
where young consumers are right now
this idea to sort of have align yourself
with brands that are consistent with
your values
we see this with the way that many gen z
folks are shopping
and so it's not surprising to me that
gen z and young millennial athletes are
operating this way too
and sarah i mean nike put out a
statement wishing simone the best but
saying that
they plan to continue to evolve and
support female athletes i mean
what what do you think is their next
move i mean you mentioned
they're going to be on full display this
summer but um you know how how do they
win back these young consumers
yeah so i think that they continue to uh
build they're really trying to put a lot
of energy behind
their women's business behind making the
garments and sneakers aimed at women
you know fine-tuning that business and
making those garments better and i think
that will help
they've also taken steps like you know
nike only just recently added maternity
workout wear
that was something they didn't even
offer that other competitors have had
for quite some time so i think those are
subtle signals to women
that they are really trying to design
for their lifestyle and for for them for
the unique needs of them as athletes hey
jason
when are these companies going to really
feel like they're they're starting to
lead
when it comes to these things and not
necessarily follow the lead of athletes
here
it certainly feels like these companies
obviously are huge and the
decision-making process is a long time
but
increasingly like you explored with your
with your business of sports
uh special that took place in georgia um
the way that
that individuals and sports teams want
to lead here
um how do you see companies doing this
i i think companies realize they need
the athletes in a much more meaningful
way i mean
it's a it's a term that's thrown around
and i'm sure sarah and i would both
and all of you as journalists would sort
of roll your eyes we all roll our eyes
when we hear about well this is a
partnership
i actually think it does have to be a
much more intimate relationship
you know between these athletes and the
companies because
as demonstrated by this simone biles
news they'll walk you know like
they have they feel much more emboldened
it used to be something where this was
only in the nba or the wnba you know
those were the examples of player
activism
and and real power this is now extending
across the entire sports landscape
across
all sorts of sports and all ages as we
talked about earlier so
i think companies need to get religion
on the fact that these athletes have
power
that is not going away and platforms
that they are very willing to use
bloomberg sarah halzak and
jason kelly a big thank you to both of
you for your time
well sticking with sports portland at
trailblazer center ines
cantor is consistently using his
platform to speak out on social justice
and human rights issues
cantor knows that there is still a long
fight ahead for equality and urges that
quote we need
unity more than anything else our
vanessa perdomo caught up with cantor
check it out so the last time we spoke
was right after
nba players protested games uh due to
the police shooting of jacob lake
and we just saw derek chovin was found
guilty
for murdering george floyd which is
another police shooting that nba players
were really outspoken against
what is the feeling like amongst players
in the league right now after this
guilty verdict was announced well you
know
like everyone else obviously i followed
the derek children trial like
most of the country not just mba players
but most of the
country you know just a friend and for
justice for
george floyd and obviously um jury you
know found them
guilty on all three accounts you know
manslaughter and
murder but uh you know they made the
decision pretty
swiftly and the facts were all there and
the evidence was all there
and the powerful video uh the whole
world saw
and we can finally say that
justice was uh served and i think it's a
huge step forward for
you know the social justice equality and
you know i believe uh you know we need
to remember that that is only just
one case of uh so many so many you know
and you know it begs the question you
know if it were not
for that video would we have this kind
of a sort of uh
justice you know and so it is well
what it takes so i believe you know
black lives always
matter no matter what so yes i feel like
this was a huge
step forward but i feel like we need to
we need to make a systematic change
and as everyone says and everyone knows
and all them vapor
players saying that we have a long fight
ahead of us so we just need to
keep uh pushing and just uh and try to
inspire our young
generation as much as that we can how do
you push forward
to make sure that this isn't just a
one-off case that this does continue
to be the um the verdict if you're an
athlete
actor singer rapper or you know if you
have a
platform i feel like we need to use this
platform to inspire as many people we
can especially our young generation the
other thing is uh
for sure you know just there there is a
bill out there called george
uh foster bill and other other thing is
that we
we definitely should uh push our
politicians
senators congressmen congresswomans to
you know just
talk about these issues more and more
because this is only
one case there are so many cases out
there uh
you know so that that's why i feel like
we need to use our
platform to try to spot as much as we
can
and you do use your platform more than a
lot of people do you're a huge advocate
for human rights
one of the things that you just teamed
up with israeli ambassador
gilad erdogan on a op-ed for
against anti-semitism can you tell me
how that partnership came to be
and why as someone who's not jewish you
still felt compelled to speak on this
issue and when i
met with ambassador they're done
obviously he's a huge
basketball fan uh i met him this last
last summer in new york me and him
sit down had an amazing conversation and
uh
you know i was like it doesn't matter
what your religion is your background or
your
your skin color or your whatever you are
you know the most important thing in
life is leave your difference on the
table and try to find what we have in
common
because we only have one world to live
you know
and so i was like let's let's bring our
powers together
and try to bring uh you know awareness
of where what's going on
not just anti-semitism but phobia and
and all the other issues around the
world because i feel like we need
unity more than everything you know so
that's why he's in big basketball and by
the way he came to our game in uh
miami down to and he had an amazing time
so
i'm glad that i have a friend like him
absolutely and speaking of unity in that
way
he's a politician and you're a
professional athlete worlds that
necessarily
a lot of people wouldn't think collide
because politics does
divide a lot of people and sports is
seen as something to bring people
together
so do you think that colliding those
worlds is even more powerful in the
message of unity
of course obviously you know because i
mean uh
i feel like you know he has a huge uh
following and obviously i have a huge
following because of the nba platform so
i feel like bring those powers
together is definitely creating more
awareness
you know he is a jewish ambassador and a
muslim athlete so when this two uh
person comes together to to to talk
about unity talk about uh islamophobia
to talk about anti-semitism talk about
what can we do to bring more
peace and love and fight against
hate you know people just stops and say
wow this is very unique we never
we never seen this kind of collaboration
before so i think it's you know it's
it's all about you know uh fighting for
uh
one thing and it's uh it's the it's the
fight against hate ennis thanks so much
for joining us and we'll
continue to look for what you and other
athletes do to help bring
social justice issues forward thank you
honestly i appreciate it
and that was portland trailblazers
center ennis cantor speaking with our
vanessa perdomo
coming up spacex has successfully sent
astronauts
into space on a rocket that's already
been used
we'll discuss what this means for the
future of space travel in two minutes
this is quick take charge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers and
industry experts via live and on-demand
webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
four three two one
zero
pretty cool stuff there hey welcome back
to quick take charge i'm jennifer
zabasaja and i'm tim stenovec in new
york well there you see four astronauts
beginning their cruise to the
international space station aboard a
spacex capital in the capsule in the
company's
first crude trip this one with a
reusable
rocket spacex has championed the goal of
designing spacecraft for multiple
missions as the only practical
and economical method to lower launch
costs and expand human
exploration specifically to mars
with us now from san francisco it's
bloomberg's ed ludlow
ed it's so great to have you on the show
to talk about this i
gotta say to our viewers to everyone
watching you pulled an all-nighter to
make this happen so we really appreciate
that
um how big of a step forward is this for
spacex
given that it's it's able to use uh
these recycled materials these these
actual recycled
products uh to uh to to to head to the
space station how big of a step is it
for the company and for the u.s space
program
yeah that's really the point here
because it's not the first time
obviously that spacex has carried human
beings to international space station we
had the demo in may of last year
and then the first crew dragon team went
up soon after that
it was the first time that the spacex
carried humans recycling both the
capsule
crew dragon the thing that the
astronauts actually sit in and the
falcon 9 rocket the booster
which propels it at launch um and it's
you know actually a question of
economics you know back when nasa relied
on the shuttle program
it was at a cost of hundreds of millions
of dollars per launch and really what
spacex has been able to do
by by reusing both the booster the
rocket and the capsule
is dramatically reduce the cost for nasa
to get human beings and supplies
and you know running supply and
maintenance missions to international
space station
which means they're more frequent we're
seeing people go up into space
more frequently humans in orbit more
frequently and as one astronaut put it
yesterday just before launch this is the
golden age of space travel that really
is the significance of
of friday's launch and ed
i mean as tim mentioned you were up all
night sort of covering the story what
was it like for you
to watch it this morning with with the
rest of the world i mean
what what was your reaction to it yeah
it's an interesting experience i
would urge viewers to go back on youtube
and what relax
watch the launch not just that one but
the crew one launch
as well because you can follow the
chronology the series of events
you know the first thing that happens is
launch of course then after about 60
seconds
uh the rocket reaches max q that's when
the rocket's under the most stress that
it will be
the thrusters go to max we're traveling
at supersonic speed
about 90 seconds later the first stage
of the rocket separates from the second
stage and crew dragon carries on
using a secondary booster a few minutes
later after that
it separates from the secondary boost of
the capsule and at that point
the capsule is 200 kilometers above
earth and and
starts to conduct this series of
complicated maneuvers but there are
risks along the way if you listen
to ground control they will give call
signs and announcements for the
different abort zones that's the
opportunity
that the dragon capsule has to disengage
to remove itself from the boosters in
the event of emergency and it also has
those three parachutes as well but it
but it's tense
and on the other side you know i'm a
journalist i want to be objective
but it's just i'm a huge space romantic
this is exciting
i like rockets i like spacex i like star
wars films who doesn't
and really you know it's completely fair
to say that what spacex and nasa have
done
excuse me over the last six months is
they've captured the imagination not
just to people in north america
but globally about what's possible
because this is the first time in a
decade
that we've launched humans from a u.s
launch
uh site the first time ever that
that a u.s agency has carried issa uh
the european space agency and japan
agency
uh uh astronauts since they shut down
the shuttle
program so we've come a long way ed i
should note that you know you say you
say romantic i
describe myself as a nerd i much prefer
the way that you describe it as a space
romantic
you know i think back though ed you know
i've been following spacex for years and
if we think back to just a few years ago
the company made history with a rocket
that landed
on the drone ship that's become routine
at this point it's not even a big deal
when the company does that anymore when
does this not become a big deal when is
it routine to just use recycled
spacecraft to send people to the iss and
beyond
well without something boring there is
some some regulatory considerations
right so the
the crew dragon the capsule is certified
for five flights
so so it has a maximum life now elon
musk was speaking on friday morning
about the falcon 9 in particular the
booster the actual rocket
and about how many times it can be
reused and
the the short answer is that they will
just keep reusing it
until it no longer works but not using
humans
as the test for that that's too risky
spacex is also working on starlink right
that is it's
a network of low orbit satellites that
provide
internet connection to people around the
world and they use the same falcon 9
booster
rocket for that as they do for the human
launches so they're basically saying
what we can do is use them
until they no longer work but remember
when spacex was founded in 2002 which
seems a long time ago now
it was with the goal of putting humans
onto other planets
i'm talking about mars so this is
incredibly exciting and we are being a
little bit futuristic
but elon musk and spacex are looking
well past supply missions and rotation
of astronauts to iss they're already
thinking about mars
and populating the human species on
other planets
and when they're able to do that with
starship the next generation of rocket
that's really when this becomes a little
redundant
all right we're gonna have to leave it
there uh space romantic bloomberg's ed
ludlow who hasn't slept at all
but is the perfect person to speak to
about this this morning ed ludlow
thanks so much hopefully you get some
sleep but we really appreciate your time
and coming up some good news about
investments made on earth day
we'll be back in two minutes this is
quick take charge
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to quick take charge i'm
tim steineveck
and i'm jennifer zabasaja in new york
let's look at some developing stories we
are tracking
this morning so in ukraine russia
is starting to withdraw thousands of
troops from areas near the ukrainian
border today ukraine
says it welcomes the move in that it
reduces tension
western leaders had called on moscow to
pull the troops
back there were fears the conflict could
lead to new economic
sanctions and in china
and in china president xi jinping's next
target in the tech crackdown is the
country's vast streams of data china is
forecast to hold
about a third of the world's data by
2025. last month
she promised to go after platform
companies that amassed data to create
monopolies
and gobble up smaller competitors and
finally
in london climate activists continued a
series of protests on friday morning
dumping a pile of fake coal outside the
lloyds of london
building blocking the entrance the
insurance rebellion group accused
lloyd's insurers of fueling climate
change by
supporting fossil fuel projects
including the adani carmichael coal mine
in australia
lloyds has said it will stop ensuring
coal oil sands and arctic energy
projects by
2030 activists activists also defaced
property of
hsbc in london yesterday
and you can get and you can get caught
up on all the days news at bloomberg.com
or
quicktake on social media well now it's
time for some quick take good news on
this friday morning thursday was earth
day and investors celebrated by pouring
a record amount of money
into a carbon market fund that punishes
polluters
the crane shares global carbon etf had
inflows of more than 15 million dollars
on
thursday bringing its total assets to
more than 160 million that's according
to some bloomberg data
it's the largest publicly traded fund
that invests in cap and trade systems
that put an added price on
burning fossil fuels on the day more
than 20 world leaders met at
biden's virtual climate summit european
union carbon futures surged to a record
exceeding more than 56 dollars and 68
cents per metric ton
it's a gain of almost 90 since the start
of 2020.
they are slightly down as of this
morning that's gonna do it for quick
take this hour but there's much more
quick take coming up in
just a minute i'm tim stenovich
and i'm jennifer zabasanja you can check
out all of these stories at bloomberg
[Music]
you